I got to high four,
three,
two,
one.
Mr Henneghan,
you were talking in the background.
Yeah.
Brian Hennigan is.
He's worried about the link he's waiting
for.
Oh,
Joe Rogan.live.
Yeah.
I should tweet it right.
I didn't.
That tweet tweet.
Tweet it while I'm talking to you.
Douglas.
Dan.
Hope the mayor of Fizz B.
Wow.
You're becoming the mayor of La.
That should be your thing,
man.
Three hundred square miles of studio
space.
A twitter.
I knew when I pulled up.
What will you.
What the Uber dropped us at the wrong
place,
but then we walked a few buildings down
and I saw a pickup truck loading epsom
salt into a side door.
I go,
yeah,
that's flotation tank shit right there.
We get the right door.
Yeah,
that's exactly what it is.
Going live with Douglas.
I only did a flotation tank once for a
shoot at your house for the man show and
you had the one in the house and we were
doing it for a shoot so you can't really
sit back and enjoy it,
but for that 30 seconds they shut the
door until they go,
uh,
action.
You're like,
wow,
this is fucking weird.
It's fucking weird.
It's weird.
And it never stops being weird.
Like even though I've done it,
I don't know how many times,
every time I do it,
it's fucking weird.
It just,
it's a very strange feeling and you
could shut it off anytime you want.
That's the best part about it.
Like I love the fact that I could just
get out of it.
Like if I,
if you want to do shrooms or something
like that,
that's a commitment.
I mean,
you're in,
you're in six,
eight hours.
You don't know where you're going or
who's going to call or stop by.
Yeah.
You can't,
that you,
you're not shaking that you're just not
going to get you.
I tweeted it.
Got It.
All right.
Beautiful.
Um,
yeah,
but the tank you just get out.
It's awesome.
Just open the door.
It's over.
I'm sure there's some kind of upkeep
that's necessary that I wouldn't do and
I'd forget and I'd go on the road and I
come back and there's bushes growing in
there.
And you know what you should do.
You should start a tank center in
Brisbane.
If nobody has money in business,
you don't,
it doesn't have to cost a lot of money.
You get like one or two tanks and you
just rent them out all day long.
Yeah,
it's a,
again,
it's like people have a disability is
the biggest form of income there.
I bet insurance will pay for it.
Maybe I made that up.
You should probably check.
Um,
I think that they'll.
Well,
I think it's a form of therapy for sure.
The point is I'm not good at upkeep.
I know you don't have to have above
ground pool that is just nothing but
algae for eight months out of the year.
Dude,
I moved into a house once in Encino and
uh,
nobody had lived in it for I guess like
over a year.
And they didn't do anything with the
pool and the pool would become this
green pond and there was schools of
mosquito larva swimming around in the
pool.
Like I was like,
why in the fuck that?
Like you could see them.
It was the weirdest thing,
man.
That's a problem with getting rid of the
fucking thing.
Dude.
It was a real problem.
Like I was looking.
I was like,
you've got like a big stew of life out
here.
There are so many mosquitoes.
Who was crazy?
There were like little schools of fish.
I was like,
this is madness.
All these little things are blood
sucking.
Little Vampires.
They're going to fly around and find
things to bite at.
Where I live,
there's no other body of water for 100
miles other than my above ground.
Crazy.
Those little cons,
you can't kill them off.
They just find a way to just breed and
like back east,
they're way worse now.
They're way worse than they are here.
It's something about the weather out
here,
I guess that keeps them in check.
The worst by far is Alaska that I've
experienced.
Have you ever experienced.
Totally shit man,
you get out of the car and they just
swarm you like huge,
huge and super aggressive and they only
live to be like three months old,
so when they're going for it,
they're just fucking going for it.
It's like some Wolf Shit.
It's like survival of the fittest with,
but it's the weirdest thing ever.
They're like,
they're a different thing.
Like we have an idea on mosquitoes.
Yeah.
They're annoying to get cheese slab.
Oh No,
no,
no.
This is a swarm is there's hundreds of
them in your face and your eyes all over
your mouth.
Everywhere.
Instantly.
Yeah.
We have no CMC.
The pool was cool when we get that
house.
It's above ground,
but it's on a slope,
so there's a deck on one side,
so it seems like an above ground pool
because you're above the pool,
but it's still an above ground pool and
it's only four feet deep or something,
but once monsoons hit look at that.
Oh my God.
That's mosquitoes in Alaska.
We're looking at what looks like a swarm
of birds.
That's the worst part about naked and
afraid.
If you ever watched that show is the
bugs.
Like I could go a month without eating.
I do that anyway.
I'm a drunk.
I get my calories from the mixer.
Are you?
Do you have to stay naked?
Like can you make clothes?
I don't know how much they cheat.
Oh No,
they have made clothes.
They were clothes.
I don't know how much they have.
The producer says,
okay,
you can make the beaver cloth but you
can't make a full like Hoodie.
They do it with every one of those
shows.
They'll call those shows reality shows,
but there's a certain amount of like
plotted out ideas and you could see them
take place.
You could see like the act you see
acting in people.
I have a whole chunk in the book that
I'm here to promote,
but about it's how I.
I'm glued to reality just to find where
they're lying.
Alright.
That's honestly.
I like the name.
Yeah.
I don't know who came up with it.
That's beautiful.
Fuck yeah.
Dude.
You're an author like a legit author.
How did that happen?
I don't know,
but you like,
you've written too,
like legitimate books.
That's pretty fucking interesting,
man.
That's a different kind of person to do
that.
Like that's um,
I've always felt like an extra one on.
One of the things that I love is.
You actually wrote this to,
you wrote,
wrote this.
There's no guy.
Yeah.
What?
No,
there's nothing wrong with those guys
because that's probably the only way
you're going to get a job,
his book.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
If a guy's not going to write it right?
Get a guy,
get a guy.
Well,
Joey Diaz could sit and tell you all
their salaries.
Yeah.
He could tell them.
Right.
And if you have a guy,
I'm just,
I could never trust anyone to write so
hard,
so hard.
I've talked to so many authors or
writers or journalists even that they'll
hand in a piece and then the editor
tweaks and changes it.
And the,
uh,
an editor got fired from the Daily News
for doing that pretty recently because
the guy had attribution's and his story,
the different studies and shit where,
where,
where he got the information that was in
the whatever the version.
And then he got accused of plagiarism
when he has the original document that
he sent to the publisher.
So the editor was the plagiarist.
The editor just decides we don't need to
tell people about that.
They made a weird judgment call and they
removed the references,
know interviews,
how often they fuck up what you said.
Like I remember I was the winner of the
Montreal Comedy Festival.
Like there's no winner in 1997.
No one wins.
Yeah.
They don't understand what that means.
But it.
Yeah,
if you,
if you read,
which I don't on purpose now you read an
interview.
You did.
I didn't say that.
Now you're making me look like a dick.
And other comics are going to see this
interview.
And I didn't say it like that.
You're like the only guy that ever won a
comedy competition that people don't
hate,
you know,
because you want San Francisco.
Like everybody that was after that was
done.
Like there was.
It wasn't a big deal and it wasn't a
hook,
but we were both completely unknown at
that point.
But still,
you weren't unknown in the comedy world,
but they'll put up the mission itself in
the late seventies.
Eighties was a huge deal.
That's when Robin Williams and Ellen
degenerate.
By the time I did it,
it was me and an unknown.
Dane Cook Bryant.
I think competitions are fucking weird
when it comes to comedy.
Like that's a change in what it is.
I like the festival idea festivals.
Nice.
We don't have to make it fucking star
search or whatever.
What are,
you know America's got talent.
It's,
it's,
it's a show.
That's what the country wants to
compete.
But here's what it did.
Introduce a lot of people,
like when they started doing the standup
show the fuck it is.
This comic standing last comic standing
was the introduction of a lot of people
got to a lot of good comics.
You know,
I mean that's how people found out about
them.
Yeah.
But as long as you know going in that
this is rigged.
Yeah.
When you're dealing with.
I just did a seattle.
I played up there while the Seattle
competition was going on and a girl I
know was in it and I had to know you
first of all,
play to yourself.
The judges are going to be people like
fucking morning show,
hack a sports talk,
Dj,
whoever they can get.
It's not real.
Just do your best if it makes you work.
That's why I liked him back in the day
because it made me work.
It made brevity important.
I have seven minutes.
Cut out the dead weight in this joke.
Get hit your fucking beats and.
But I knew that it's bullshit,
you know?
Yeah man,
it's,
I'm,
I'm sure I won because I was way cooler
than Dane Cook.
And I hung out and drank.
Drank with the fucking producers.
And what,
wait a minute.
Why would you say that?
I mean,
wouldn't you just win cause you did a
great job.
Really funny.
Human beings aren't.
Oh,
utilizable what?
San Francisco,
aren't they a little bit more open
minded and intelligent than the rest of
the country where the people that hired
the judges,
that producer,
I forget her name,
that I hung out with the whole three
weeks and we'd drink and have fun and it
probably helped,
but they appreciated you.
Before that I was the judge a year or
two later when I want to keep being self
deprecating with James Inman.
One,
I was a judge Acadians.
It bothers me when James Edmond one.
I was a judge and he's still a good
comic.
He's a funny guy,
eh?
I see.
It's funny,
but hey look,
my point is last comic standing.
Let a lot of people know Lonzo Bowden,
you know,
I'm half round was the first year he
lost a Dat Phan,
which I said on twitter is what killed
him.
He couldn't get over the shame even 20
years later or 15 is that fans still
around?
I've looked them up.
Uh,
every here and again.
You remember Dat Phan and you search to
see and those occasionally he'd be
playing a casino.
He was a guy that I felt like there's
some really unbalanced hatred towards.
It was very odd when he won last comic
standing,
people were really mad.
There was a certain percentage of comics
that were really mad and let me tell you
something.
I was there when he had a set and he
fucking killed.
He fucking killed whether or not you
like that kind of material or not.
There was like he got up a bunch of
hatred.
Was wasn't just.
He wasn't a young guy like,
wow,
what was it,
Craig?
Because Eliza one last comic standing
when she was like three years in.
Right.
I think she said that she didn't.
She said that three or four years in.
I hope I don't say the wrong years,
but I mean that's kind of the same thing
along the same lines,
right?
Like you're getting in,
but if you do it,
you do it.
Sure.
You,
when you've got eight minutes to kill,
you can break it up and for whatever
reason,
man,
people are so pissed at him because he
was kind of fresh to comedy,
right?
Like he hadn't been ridiculous.
He was one of those scientists that you
hate.
He sat down and he grabbed the laughs
per minute.
He's getting based on his recordings of
his sets and really did that on last
comic standing.
He'd have these graphs of laughs.
That's interesting.
Why do I hate that?
I don't know.
We were talking about this on a podcast
yesterday where like the all the people
that you were trained to hate.
We're talking about like carrot top and
the nineties.
You hated carrot top as a comedian.
You kinda had to hate him.
And then he beat Bill Hicks for some
comedy award back when they had comedy
awards.
Uh,
what's also the prop thing,
for whatever reason,
a prop comic is a lesser man,
right?
But he's essentially,
he's the last guy that's going to
interfere with us.
He no one's flipping a coin between
carrot top and Joe Rogan.
Well,
yeah.
And,
but I think there's enough to go around
even if they were like this shit,
but I'm saying all that hatred.
And we were talking about Dennis Leary,
who I listened to on stern and I really
loved the interview and I liked Denis
leary and I realized it was just all
that he stole Bill Hicks Persona thing,
that I just hated him for that.
And you get old and you go,
I don't really give a shit.
Yeah.
And when do you let it go?
Yeah,
Wendy let it go when we're old and go,
fuck yeah.
We were joking around before the show
about how to send off an email and he's
probably talking to someone on twitter
or no,
fuck your mother,
like you imagine in that guy is still
doing that all the time.
Like God damn thatall right?
I talked to Owen Benjamin and he's like,
dude,
sometimes I don't sleep.
I'm like,
listen to me man.
You've got to stop doing that because
Owen will fucking go to war on twitter
all day.
And Jamie Kilstein,
Jamie Kilstein was on and he was pretty
open about how he would be when he was
all social justice,
Warrior it out.
He would get crazy with his phone and
these arguments where he couldn't think
of anything,
but he was constantly pulling his phone
out,
checking and what did they say?
What they say,
well,
fuck them.
You fucking cisgender piece of shit or
whatever the fuck you get mad with it.
You get obsessed.
I just say,
don't do it folks.
Avoid arguments in real life,
especially when you're arguing down.
You might be,
you know,
you might be like going to war with
someone who's on your own level.
Yeah,
I'd argue on A.
There's a couple of recent things were
friends of mine are arguing.
You know that you look like a fucking
open mic or when you,
when you have these arguments in
business with people who are far your
underlings.
Well it's just.
I mean I just really feel like we should
try for meaningful discussion with
friendly people and just figure out what
the fuck we disagree on,
but that's where I get trapped is I'm
the guy that when the Jehovah's witness
comes to my door,
you start to find them the mood I'm
going to,
I'm going to prove them wrong.
And the less sense they make,
the harder that fucking wood is to knock
on how you store.
They used to be my thing.
I would always want to argue with people
about.
Especially about like if someone
had had some ridiculous religious
belief,
I would always argue with them about it.
And now I don't.
I don't care.
Like as long as I'm nice,
I think it's.
I think it helps a lot of people I
really do and it.
And even if they're not right,
here's the thing,
if you live like it's true,
it is right while you're alive,
if you live like it's true.
Like we look at it like almost from two
dimensions when there's like multiple
dimensions to the idea of religion.
Because even though it probably,
there was never a time where a guy came
back from the dead.
There's probably never a time where a
guy walked on water.
But if you buy the idea of this person
and this person's goal for humanity and
move toward the directions,
like moving towards love and compassion
and treating each other as equals.
I mean that's like the whole Jesus
thing.
So even if it's it never really weird
superstition,
that was the catalyst to make you a
decent person.
Yeah,
I think like all human things,
he gets poisoned along the way.
But the idea behind it,
if even if you don't think it's true,
if you treat it like it's true,
it is true.
Like you really will make a better
world.
It sounds like super hippie.
No,
that's twisty shit.
And if you have some mental illness that
makes you believe you're driving a
cadillac,
you're driving a fucking Cadillac,
but you know how we have laws and we
have certain ways that we behave and we
have agreements with how we dress and
the words we use,
the phrases.
If there was a religion that was all
super positive that we just all agreed
to adopt just the same way we adopt all
the other things that we do in our
lives.
All the other normal shit we do with the
way we decided to dress or cars we
drive.
Just adopt that in there too.
Like this is.
This is just how we behave.
We behave as this as if we are souls in
a vessel created by the great one who
knows everything and has a plan for us
all and we should be kind to each other
and move in the direction of love and
harmony.
I mean,
that's basically what all religions.
Some Cock sucker that says,
oh yeah,
that a great entity just spoke to me
directly in my bedroom and we're going
to have a different sect of religion.
There's a fucking funny show on Netflix
about that.
The unbreakable,
Kimmy Schmidt was a woman who was in a
sex cult who was in the backyard,
like trapped in a basement for like
months with some.
I don't know.
I mean,
I don't know how it's yours.
I think it was supposed to be.
It's a really funny show though,
and she gets.
Have you seen it?
Wait,
is it a show?
A show?
It's a sitcom on Netflix.
It's called the unbreakable Kimmy
Schmidt.
I think Tina fey is one of the people,
the creative people on it.
Fucking funny show man.
Like really funny.
Like so overdue to get caught up on
Netflix binges.
Oh Man.
Yeah,
it seems like it's been two years of
just as something I gotta do I need new
ones?
I need to catch up on old ones.
A plug.
Nathan,
for you.
Have you watched Nathan for you on
comedy central?
No.
What is it?
Is one of the funniest fucking shows
ever.
Completely underrated.
You have to understand what it is going
in.
It's basically like a bar rescue,
but a fake a.
it's basically a hidden camera show,
but open hidden camera.
It's like a bar rescue kitchen
nightmares,
Nathan.
Uh,
what's the God,
goddammit?
Google it.
Nathan something Jewish.
Uh,
Nathan fielder.
And he's A.
Yes,
he does for small business.
He uh,
he helps small businesses.
This guy,
it's,
he's so uncomfortable to watch.
I can't do it justice.
You have to watch Nathan for you.
So these people with small businesses
think it's a real show and they come on
and he helps them with their problems
and it's,
it's,
it's so amazingly layered in watch the
one with the,
uh,
the guy that has the,
a TV shop that can't compete with best
buy and there's so many layers.
I put it on my phone,
I trusted implicitly pleased,
watch it and then tweet about it because
it's fucking brilliant and I'll just
embarrass it by trying to explain it.
If there's anything,
any prominent,
how with Netflix is that sometimes I
don't know what I'm looking for.
You know,
like there's a lot of shows that turns
out like,
Whoa,
this is a four seasons of this and you
never heard of it.
Like maybe it's just me.
Maybe I'm that.
And it's totally possible because
there's always some fucking new musical
artists.
And I go,
who the fuck is that?
And I'll go to their instagram page.
They have 14 million followers.
And I'm like,
oh,
it's me.
I'm that old man.
I'm that old band.
Doesn't know Jack Shit.
We
had a uber coming here.
Was this old prolly Armenian guy,
probably sixties racist.
Triggered a start the show.
He uh,
he's listening to what I assume he
thinks people want to listen to and it's
all this shit.
I couldn't name you a fucking Jz from a
that kind of shit.
I don't know any of it.
And I'm about to say,
hey,
you don't have to play this for us.
But then I,
I saw him lip sinking to the lyrics and
tapping his fingers.
Oh,
on the steering wheel.
I'm like,
wow,
how out of the loop of my fucking 60
year old for an uber,
Uber drivers know all the words to these
fucking songs.
But you never been a music guy.
No,
you don't like music now that's,
that's something that it's not possible.
I mean,
I have songs I like,
wait,
what's a great song like Doug,
Stan hope here's.
He goes,
oh yeah,
sits back.
Most of the new songs that I've,
I've learned I've either heard playing
in a store or on a commercial and I go,
ah,
that's catchy.
Do you latch,
chat,
chat?
I don't know that I love you.
Chop chop chop by a Jimmy.
Yeah,
it's from like 1997 was on the
soundtrack of the movie go.
And then they disappeared.
You can't even find where the band is
now,
but it was on a corona commercial and I
love it and I use it as intro music all
the time.
That pumps me up.
There you go.
Sing a song.
Well,
give me some volume.
See,
I'm just seeing the video on
mute.
I'm into this song.
This is great.
Headphones.
No,
no,
that.
I love you always.
Again,
I like how these gals are dressed like
they're 19 fifties.
Cover girls.
What is about that look,
right?
That like cover,
you know,
pinup girl.
That's what it's called.
Nineteen fifties.
Pinup girl type of.
Look.
What is it about that feeling?
Maybe it makes fat chicks look good.
Doug.
Stan hope.
Do you not realize it was a different
day and age?
You can't say that anymore.
Those days are done.
What's wrong with a fat girl looking
good?
What's wrong with you?
You just need to just find out what able
is to meet Dave Bliss.
Ablest.
I'd read.
I saw someone write a bus.
I'm like,
do I really want to go in?
And they say,
it's got to be a handicapable.
Exactly.
You're your person that doesn't get the
words,
but if you are mocking someone who's
like literally stupid or low watt
Gurgler in a high back chair.
Exactly.
You're,
you're,
you're enabling,
you call people idiots.
You're enabling.
Yup.
That was my last special.
I did a whole bit about,
it's called the euphemism treadmill
where you can't say retarded because.
But retarded was the clinical term
because before that they were called
imbeciles and morons or they were called
Mongoloid idiots.
Yeah.
And that's what it was for kids with
downs.
They kept changing it and then we kept
making fun of them with the new name so
they had to change the new name to
something else and then we'd make fun of
what the new name under the punchline to
the entire long bit was,
you know,
if you went straight clinical
definition,
American Medical Association and you
said,
Oh uh,
and you made that stick.
That's what I'm going to make fun of you
for.
When you slip on a banana peel.
Oh,
you just exhibited some of the Atlanto
axial instability usually associated
with the trisomy 21 genetic disorder.
You fucking stage funny by seven was
bored with the trisomy 21.
Chromosomal imbalance.
Yeah.
There's certain things can make fun of
white people.
White people are failure.
Fair game.
You can be racist as fuck.
Sure.
Especially if you're a white guy.
You hate white people making fun of
lawyers.
They last long with you because they own
everything.
Yeah.
Lawyers are good.
One to make fun of,
but he can't make fun of Jews.
Well,
yeah.
Jew is just one of those words where
it's all in the inflection as to whether
or not he fucking Jew.
Whoa.
Right.
It's all been.
No.
You know,
the Jews are a people that that's fine,
but if you say Joe.
Yeah.
Like you say,
if you say I'm all about Jews,
that's okay.
Yeah.
I'm all about Jews.
Just like hanging out with Jews.
That's a only Jews.
People would go there in the town like
you'd be okay.
That's all right.
People accept that,
but it feel like,
God,
I'm tired of all these Jews.
Unacceptable.
Y,
W.
I overdosed on Jews.
I was just around nothing but Jews for
like months and there's too many one in
Armenian in my life for a few days I
talked to somebody I never do sets.
If I come to town and I'm hanging at the
comedy store,
it's to talk to you and drinking the
back bar and hang out.
Hey,
do you want to do is set no fucking way.
Do I ever want to do a set for normal
people?
I.
I paid my fucking dues.
I made my bones to have a small niche
fan base that are defendable.
Doug,
I got news for you.
Okay.
I hate to do this to you again,
but they're here like your fans are
here.
Your fans or fans or in La,
they would love it if you did a set.
They're like,
it's not like they wouldn't go through.
you have a lot of fans.
You fuckhead doctor with this niche
group.
That's horseshit.
People know you're funny.
I'm tired of this.
I'm talking about when it's just a mixed
bill of fucking love.
You scatter shot this 400 people.
I bet 320 of them are your fans.
First of all,
you know this well.
You still do some shit.
I saw you last time I saw you.
You were doing one of those weird shows
where people just called out premises,
stand up on the spot and you fucking
destroyed it,
and you told me afterwards,
none of that was planned.
You had none of that in your holster.
All of that was off the top of your
head,
which is fantastic.
I was high as a kite.
I barely knew what I was saying.
It's for me to do material.
I can't do you.
Fifteen minutes.
One minute.
Give me a mental hugs.
Come into the embrace of the comedy
store to stop this.
Why is,
why would I do it outside of my own
comfort zone?
Don't you aren't in your comfort zone.
Your comfort zone is everywhere.
If I went up on stage,
if I came to town,
which I rarely do,
I get to see you and a million people I
never see all in one room and everybody
loves to see you too,
but if I went on stage,
then I would have this whole anxiety,
well,
that sucked,
and then I'd be apologizing for my set.
Oh,
great.
Set says Greg proops or someone and then
you're like,
it wasn't good.
I forgot this tag and that tag and I
rather than just hanging out and
enjoying myself,
so fuck it.
Bucket.
So here's the thing though,
and this is,
I'm going to say this with all
sincerity,
there's more understanding and
camaraderie at the store right now than
any place I've ever been at any time.
And even when we have bad sets,
like people have someone have a bad set
and like,
how was it dude?
I could not connect with those people.
Like someone will say,
you know,
we'll be fill Arkansas.
Then the comedy store,
the front of my peers somewhere.
No one will see it.
You talk about it and you learn
something from it and you.
It's like it's a weird environment,
but it fosters new shit.
It fosters new ideas and taglines and
which I was going to say about twitter
battles.
I got so much good material out of
fighting these,
whatever it was at the time,
my space,
twitter,
facebook before that news groups and
getting into these angry,
ugly arguments.
When I'm writing,
I'm writing paragraphs in defense of and
guess what?
Oh I have 15 minutes because some stooge
annoyed me on a dot comedy standup news
group and I spent all night fighting,
accidentally wrote a new act.
That's actually probably a good use of
it if you could see you and I are very
different in that regard.
I would rather just not talk to those
people,
but if you did want to go to war,
which I used to do,
you can get some material out of that
for sure.
Because you're forcing yourself to think
again anytime you forced yourself to
her.
Like I've found that like the best shit
that I ever write.
I write completely free form where I
don't know,
I just like,
I'll,
I'll just start thinking about,
uh,
any subject and just start writing.
I'm not specifically try to write jokes
and on,
on the way I can like Kinda suck those
jokes out of there.
Do you do that?
How do you.
It depends on the,
the,
the premise,
but the best premises I have,
I write like a defense attorney.
So.
And then we can look at it,
login the jokes afterwards,
once the justice has left the courtroom,
all rise.
Then you put it in the fist fuck jokes.
Yeah.
There's,
there's a gut.
It's super important to have a balance.
Right.
And you got to find out where that
balance is.
Like when you can get away with a
premise,
you know,
you've got to stack it just right.
I could just stack it the wrong way one
way.
And you look like you're patronizing and
you're full of shit.
Stack at the wrong way the other way you
look like,
or a sexist or a Republican and secret
man.
Do I have notes?
The new current current climate?
Yeah,
I'm sure.
Right?
Imagine working for a television show.
I wanted to bring this up.
I'm glad we just got to talking about
this.
Sam Cedar got fired yesterday.
I missed this.
So can I just saw someone on twitter
deal?
Sam Cedar,
who's a heavy leftwing fellow who um,
was apparently in some sort of a dispute
with the alt right.
I don't know what was going on.
I think it was about Roy Moore.
Like there's one of those things and
they pulled up a tweet of his and took
it out of context from 2009 and that
suite was.
I'm going to paraphrase it,
I don't want to fuck it up.
Jane.
Actually Jamie,
pull it up so we can find the exact
tweet.
You know that if you paraphrase it,
you're going to sound funnier than he
would.
It wasn't that funny road interact.
If I was going to edit your act,
this is how you fight it.
He just actually,
here's one minute ago.
Here's essentially what it is.
If you can't find it,
you got to find it and you've got to
find the.
Because I don't want to fuck this up.
I can't tell you how many times I've
told Hennigan about now this comment,
you get to see this is a great comic.
They do this bit and I do the bit for
them and he's like,
oh,
that's funny.
And then he sees them.
Me,
Oh,
you do it so much better than the other
guys.
Got Too many words.
Too many words.
He's Irish.
Guilted into retarded.
Distracting you with admitted premise.
Um,
but anyway,
ms NBC got a swarm of emails like the,
these people like attacked,
know these alt right fellows attacked
and started saying that this guy had
tweeted a which essentially a rape joke
and that we would never sponsored you
and we're going to contact your
sponsors.
This is what he said.
You got a thing covering over the,
a picture of it.
Don't care.
Oh,
I eat.
go,
don't care our,
he polanski.
But I hope if my daughter is ever raped
by an older truly talented man with a
great.
Oh I.
But I hope if my daughter is ever raped,
it is by an older truly talented man
with a great sense of Nissan Nissan
scenes.
I don't know.
That's what it is,
is a,
this.
Here's the part,
here's the part of the problem.
He deleted this which he regrets doing
it,
but it's a part of a series of tweets.
All of them that criticize people
support of Roman Polanski because Roman
Polanski had raped kids,
but he did really good films and he was
like,
just fucking disgusting.
That is.
He was essentially saying,
this is a horrific way to look at this.
Like this guy raped a baby,
right?
He raped like a 13 year old.
Yeah.
Right.
So this was a part of a series of tweets
all expressing this and that was clearly
satire and MSNBC capitulated and they
fired him.
And uh,
I,
you know,
I don't know him.
I know people who do know him,
some that like,
um,
you know,
and it's,
uh,
it is not,
I don't have a dog in this fight,
but that's crazy.
That's crazy.
If you look at what this,
the joke was and that the fact that he
deleted it and then on top of that,
the.
Is he apologizing for it?
No,
he's not.
He's not.
What he did was he made a video
explaining what the joke was,
why he said it,
and the fact that it was a part of a
series of tweets that he said,
but it doesn't matter.
Once that fucking outrage machine,
I was just asked if I regret my tweet
from 2009,
I regret.
Laziness led me to delete it.
I would never regret criticizing rape
apologists.
And I agree with that tactic.
I don't know Sam Cedar.
I don't either,
but I know that he could probably start
a podcast and make a decent living and
not have to work for someone who's going
to fire him.
Well,
he,
I think he has his own show minority
report,
right?
Isn't that his own show?
He does that.
His own Internet show because that's
what he loved it.
Yeah.
And you know,
and here's the other thing,
he isn't.
He had a dispute more than once,
I believe,
with my good friend Sam Harris.
And he accused Sam Harris of being the
name.
Sounds familiar,
Sam Harrison,
neuroscientists.
Some people don't like that term.
They don't.
He's an author's runs,
has a podcast.
He's essentially an intellectual,
very,
very smart guy.
Like one of the smartest guys I ever
have my podcast.
So what was their beef?
Sam Harris believes that all ideologies
are inherently dangerous and Islam is
very problematic.
And many people on the left think that
when you criticize Islam that you are
some sort of a racist.
You're akin to a racist.
Whereas if you criticize Christianity
here,
someone was just not a rube right
against that weird thing because of
brown skin and people's desire to not be
perceived as racist so they go way
overboard with it and which is what's
happening with the me too thing where
you go,
I see all the benefits of people coming
out and it's putting the fear in a
fucking.
Everybody who let me die,
fuck 20 years ago.
Exactly.
No,
but I just wanted to just for Sam Sake,
like he's not a racist by any stretch of
the imagination.
He doesn't like ideologies.
He doesn't like something that makes you
think that God wants you to kill people.
He doesn't want.
I mean,
whether or not you interpret that the
way the Christians do.
I mean there's not a lot of people
killing people over some shit from the
Old Testament.
You know,
there's no one out there in the acting
the rate the rates of God for people
wearing two different types of cloth.
Right.
Because Christians are generally better
off and yeah,
once you get a lot of fucking toys and
yeah.
You Dismiss a lot of that.
I should kill myself in the name of
blank.
That's a fucking good point.
You know,
and I've always wondered if you look at
like the Middle East,
you're not looking at like rushed,
lush tropical forests and beautiful
beaches like Brazil.
You know where everybody's happy and
they want to play fucking volleyball on
the beach.
Do Jujitsu.
Everybody's having a party.
No,
it's not the Saudi princes,
they will still wear the garb,
but then once they get behind the gold
plated palace doors.
Yeah,
there's dixit swinging and fucking
champagne flowing,
but outside it's all sand for people
that have nothing better.
That's why Jesus works in the Mideast
Midwest where you're in fucking Indiana
and you have fields to plow and it's
gonna be Shitty,
great.
Angry whether,
and maybe Jesus is the only thing
getting you through another year,
another harvest and you put a marble on
the highway and it just sits there.
It doesn't keep rolling.
There's no hills bitch.
Snow hits the fucking worst.
Indiana is the worst state in the
country,
but even in Indiana they found gold and
it became like Qatar.
Some shit.
They just,
you know,
they found oil,
they felt like some crazy new patch oil
and all of a sudden they started
building the world's tallest building
there and the same kind of shit they do
in Dubai.
We do buy apparently is insane now.
They have indoor surfing things in Dubai
in the middle.
Did you get a surfboard and your indoor
surfing?
You could ski in doors.
They've indoor skiing in Dubai and
you're going to have that here in the
compound.
Do you have a name for this new uh,
towns and it's kind of worn.
Yeah.
Plus I think Anthony Kumi,
Anthony Kumina,
who I have to give him his props to.
He's probably the reason why I started a
podcast.
It was,
first of all,
because he was a part of opiod anthony,
which was the first time I ever thought
like,
I really liked doing radio or the way
opie and Anthony did it.
It was great.
We would come in.
You,
you have done it too,
right?
Yeah.
But I remember first doing it going,
wow,
am I the shitty episode?
Because no one really talked a lot.
We just had fun.
I know I,
it took me a minute to,
oh,
they just decided to do what they wanted
to do with radio.
I just thought I was boring because
there's no bells and whistles and fake
laughs and to this day I don't think
opie and Anthony got the credit that it
deserved because I think that they let
us,
they let us like they're the best show.
They were the best show ever.
They don't exist anymore,
unfortunately,
but they were the best show ever to go
on today exist in their own world?
They do.
I know Anthony does and he still has.
This was recently fired.
I don't,
I don't know what I just know.
He started his own thing.
Norton's still doing his thing with Sam
Norton this still doing this thing with
Sam and Norton does a thing with the UFC
too.
He does UFC uncensored with Matt Serra,
which is hilarious.
And Norton also does the chip chip
person podcasts.
He does all that on his own now.
Yeah.
I've never listened to it,
but I've been tweeted about it enough to
know that it's a character.
It's hilarious.
It's so uncomfortable.
It's so good.
It's one of my favorite things that he
does.
It's fucking amazing.
You want to see a video of it right now
we're in a live broadcast.
No,
but I'll pull it up sometimes.
I hated making people listen to 30
seconds of Chacho.
It was good.
I liked it.
Good.
Let people know.
A lot of people don't know.
There's a lot of shit people don't know.
You know,
there's only one way to find out.
Someone has to tell you.
I find out from commercials that a
little help at work,
you know?
I know coronas still sucks as beer,
but I liked the song that you use.
Thank you,
dear you.
Are they a sponsor to corona with a lime
feminine?
Some tropical climate and I want a beer,
but I don't really want a beer.
Yeah,
that's.
I want a soda,
but I want to stay drunk.
You know what a Moscow mule is?
Yeah.
What is that?
It's some drink,
but they,
uh,
there was a surplus of copper at the
time.
So the guy in order to get rid of copper
said,
oh,
you have to drink it out of a copper
cup,
and it was just a big room and now
copper and it's going to be in a copper
cup and I don't know how they did that
with corona and alive.
Oh No.
You put a lime in this beer.
Yeah,
that's true.
Right?
Why does it have a lime?
And every now and then someone sticks
alignment at Dos equis and you're like,
what?
What is this?
Wow.
You've become judgmental drinking years.
Yeah,
I'll get weird.
You know,
get weird when it comes to drinks.
But Corona is not a bad beer.
It's just not a strong beer.
It's fine.
When I'm in a place that's dark,
I like to drink real shit.
I like to drink like an IPA or Guinness
or Jack Daniels.
That's what I like to drink in a
darkened.
I like a dark wood environment.
This is Shitty neon lights.
This.
Your studio is a great dark.
This is a bar they I would go to.
I would go dark hardwood bar.
It's a little bright.
I'd be like,
it's kind of annoying in this place.
It's like if the cameras weren't on
drinking,
this is no.
If you came out of that bright sunlight.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
This would be common into this he brick,
especially if it's hot outside,
which by the way it might get hot here
any minute now.
There is a fucking fire in Ventura and
the winds are insane right now in the
fire.
V Through Ventura is just tearing things
apart.
Got The alert on my phone and the Uber
drive over.
Be careful warning warning's bad man.
I mean it is bad and it scares the shit
out of me because I left a kid
somewhere.
Yes,
there's that for sure.
Um,
but what it scares the shit out of me is
that in the short term,
I think most people are going to get out
of there if they prepare and move
accordingly.
But you gotta you gotta realize what
this is like.
This is something that when you get a
fire of this size,
it's burned back that up a little bit.
So you get the numbers just in today is
burned 45,000
acres destroyed at least 150 structures,
force 20,000
people,
27,000
people to evacuate and they can't stop
it.
They don't have enough manpower.
When when something is this big and it's
this strong and the winds are this
fucking crazy.
You look at how those trees are blown
over sideways and these fucking houses
are up in flames and it's how do they
even have enough water?
I have no idea.
I Live City Hall just burned down the
city hall building and just them putting
the fire out.
Everyone's water went out.
It was not enough water.
You couldn't turn on your taps because
they used it all to put out city all.
I wonder
if there's like a chart where you could
see where you could go back to nine
slash 11 and post nine slash 11.
How many women got impregnated by
firefighters?
Like how many?
Remember when firefighters,
like after nine slash 11,
remember they were real heroes.
People have kind of like taking them for
granted until they do something to
actually save your house.
I used to do that bit about after nine
slash 11 firefighters and cops are
getting so much hero pussy.
They were launching it like a rotted
doctopus out of,
out of,
what do you call those?
Slingshots slingshots.
They'd have to swat him down with tennis
rackets.
I had this whole bit about Europe was so
true,
right?
Yeah.
No,
not.
Well then the war came and then all the,
I think the bit was all the troops are
getting the hero pussy that nine slash
11 first responders used to get and now
they're just hanging around bars.
Go remember me?
Yeah man.
Do you know Google has this crazy thing
on his phone when I was paying attention
to recently where you,
um,
you say something like,
hello,
my name is Doug Stanhope.
And then it translates it out loud to
someone else.
Like through your phone,
they talk to your phone and they'll say,
you know,
may Abolo Pedro.
I am,
I,
they go through the thing.
It translates it and then it changes it
in your ear to what English is the
English version of that apple fish.
What's it called?
Babel fish was on the hitchhiker's guide
to the galaxy.
Oh,
okay.
So apple fish as a fish.
I saw this.
It's a new feature on this phone call,
the Google Pixel,
and I said,
I don't think people.
And you have to have these Pixel earbuds
that do it,
or you can actually do it through the
phone,
I think without the ear buds,
but I don't think people understand how
crazy this is.
Like if they're just starting this thing
out,
like it used to be.
You couldn't really talk to your phone.
Now you could.
You could do a google search by just
pressing that speaker button and say who
is Brian Hennigan?
And then a boot put in like seconds.
It'll pull up your wikipedia who doug
stanhope in seconds,
like what is going to.
If they can do this thing right,
we're going to have a thing in our ear
like little earbud and you're gonna be
able to talk to people all over the
fucking planet.
It's going to get super strange.
People that speak Arabic languages,
so people that in South America you're
going to get.
I still every so many of these
technological advances,
I think about you and your bits back in
the day.
Why do they have all these things on the
cell phone that replaced what a cell
phone is?
Yeah.
Well,
why you making me read texts me,
it takes me four buttons to make an act
and ask.
Call me.
Just call me.
Back then.
I would've never thought that text
messaging would become popular.
That there's a bit that you could never
do today.
I could only do that bit in 2005.
When it was like people were starting to
send you text messages like without fuck
is this.
You would get on your phone.
You'd go,
why don't you just call me stupid?
Why are you making me reply with my
thumb?
Well,
that's
awkward.
Shows how much you don't really want to
talk to your friends.
I don't want to have to say,
hey,
how you been?
What's going on?
How's the kids?
How's your sister?
Yeah.
I just need one simple response.
I respect Joey Diaz for that.
Joey Diaz will not do that with you and
I think he's right.
I'm thinking about it more and more
lately.
Have these weird text message
conversations with the people.
I'm like,
why am I doing this?
I need to look at you.
You need to know.
I like you like the friends.
If we're going to socialize,
don't text me.
Hey,
how's it going?
That's a bar conversation.
You can see me in a bar.
I don't want to sit and catch up via
text.
Hey,
how about that one in a long time?
have I just.
Hey.
Yeah.
Hey,
fuck.
Is this?
What?
Are you 12?
You can't get my phone.
Kids got my phone number.
Motherfucker.
What's going on?
Hey,
see me in a bar and then sit down and
say,
Hey,
12 what?
Hey.
Hi.
You can say that to your friend.
Like,
Hey,
hey.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but usually that's the extent of what I
have to say.
Anyway.
Got It.
All right.
High Five,
high five on text,
but you'd probably have a,
an Emoji.
Can't hey on text and you definitely
can't do.
You can't yo you lazy.
Fuck you want to talk?
You ain't got shit to say.
Yo.
I need affirmation that we're still
friends,
just,
you know,
it's kind of part of the business.
We're not going to be close friends over
a quarter of a century just because of
text messaging.
I don't live in your town.
You're going to lose Brownie points if
you just type Yo.
You're going to have to have like,
Yo,
are we still having lunch?
are we going to the game?
Like I texted you a week ago.
Hey,
what time are we doing that podcast?
Because he's supposed to set up other
shit around it,
but then I said in parentheses that I
don't want to do,
so I'm glad you didn't get back to me.
I'm so glad I helped you.
Yes you did.
We going to procrastinate broken.
I go Rogan's podcast or like nine hours
and we're not going to be able to fit
other ones in.
It's unfortunate,
but what is fortunate it is.
This is not famous available right now.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Joe Rogan stories are in there.
Oh beautiful.
It has an index.
I do have.
I have a lot of fucking name drops in
there.
We had some good times,
you know that the story that we were
talking about in question you have to
read about in the book,
but it involves Doug,
Stan hope and I in the desert that Dale.
I'm sure we've talked about it.
I know we have too many times.
Then afterwards go into that Lakers game
few days later.
Yeah.
That was a weird one,
right?
Yeah.
In the height of nine slash 11 patriotic
fever and was like,
this is nuts.
You guys are going crazy.
Like you're standing up for a basketball
game.
This is.
I remember when you picked me up at
curse on for that game.
You add a,
I don't know,
an suv of some kind of.
It's probably a suburban.
Was pissing off in Denali.
You've got a white Yukon Denali and you
were pissing out the door while we were
high on mushrooms going 65 miles an hour
down the highway deaths door open and
he's like pissing out the door.
Probably Piss all over my truck,
but this is as the wars kicking off.
Two thousand three,
I believe.
We saw the war.
We saw the war kickoff.
I'm like,
it was the superbowl like it was
planned.
I spell all this out and you will.
You said it.
I remember you said it.
You said,
oh my God,
there's a kickoff.
We were ahead of the curve.
Joe Rogan was with technology because
when you pick me up in that,
that's the first time I heard gps say in
400 feet.
Take a right onto the one.
Oh one.
And also you had cell phone video
because you videotaped me pissing out
your door.
Just 2003.
It was 2003.
You know the best picture I ever took on
my cell phone.
This is like affirmed the need to have a
camera on you at all times.
I was in downtown La and there was this
overweight black hooker with a crazy wig
on and sunglasses and she was eating a
meatball sub and I looked over and she
goes,
hey baby.
And she pulls her tit out and she's got
her tit and one hand and I took a
picture of this.
See if you can find that.
It's.
I know it's out there.
I couldn't.
It's,
it looks so amazing.
I couldn't,
I couldn't believe it,
and I took it with one of those Motorola
flip phones back in 2000 because we were
filming fear factor downtown La and this
lady was walking around with their tear
out.
I was like,
this is a lawyer.
She was smiling and laughing and I took
a picture of her with her tit out and
uh,
to me to this day is like,
now I know.
Why wouldn't want to know that you're
taking a picture.
Nobody knew anything.
It was like to,
to think that just a few years later the
iphone will come out,
you know,
2007.
The iphone comes out and now you can't
imagine anybody not have one of
everything.
If you,
if you,
if you're around someone and they don't
have a smartphone,
you look at it like there's some kind of
freak.
Becker is the only one that becker my
oldest best friend from forever still
doesn't have a cell phone.
Yeah.
My friend Steve doesn't have a phone.
His wife fucking hates state.
It is.
That's the picture.
That's a real picture.
Please take a screenshot of that and
save it for me because I keep losing it.
Why do you say that?
So happy,
but come on son.
Look at that picture.
She's enormous.
She's got a meatball sub in her hand.
It's the perfect picture.
Jamie,
I want you to order up a large hd
version of this.
Have some scientists convert that we're
gonna.
Make a poster out of that.
That needs to be on the wall.
One hundred percent.
Put it on.
You know,
don't put it on Youtube,
but that's got to remind me of this.
Get the crew on it.
We need to have that photo on our wall.
That's my one of my happiest moments.
I swear to God.
I went back to work.
I was fucking howled and laughing
because I had a lady was funny.
She looked at me,
Oh,
you want some of this?
And she pulled the content out and then
she smiles and starts laughing at me.
All the while she's eating a meatball
sub.
That's a great picture.
Palming that sub like it's a a 45 and a
old west shootout and God helped her tit
the way she's got a death grip on that
ticket.
I was like,
she gets some sort of a cobra choke.
That's.
Yeah,
that's,
that's how I have to choke my dick to
keep it up when I'm drunk.
You get almost like your whole cock ring
queue.
Like you get it,
like you're making a bridge pinching
down on your dick a hard fight.
The boobs fight.
The Bose Mr.
Penis.
Yeah.
That's a great picture though.
That's an important moment for me
because I'm like,
okay,
now I know I'm into this stuff.
It was so I could capture that picture.
I was happy for days because I remember
looking at it go and that's real.
Like I always see those.
You see those crazy pictures online,
you know who took that,
what happened?
But I took that.
I was there.
I like that was real,
like it was really.
I didn't pay that lady.
It was just happened to be.
I said hi to her.
I had my phone out and she looked at me
and pulled her tit out and I hit the
camera button.
Then it got it.
So it wasn't supposed to happen.
That is your sailor kissing the girl in
Times Square.
Thank you.
Thank you,
Mr Hannigan.
You're right.
Planting the flag at all.
Accept that.
I feel like it's my magnum opus Codec.
Choke it.
It might've been the best thing I've
ever done.
Needs a cocktail.
I get ice right here.
I don't like that.
That lady is doing that for a living.
I was not doing a wish her living
anymore.
Probably dead,
but I wish our prosperity and happiness
and I hope she found Jesus the next
moment after I took that picture.
And then.
But you can't fix everybody,
but sometimes you just got to let people
be crazy.
I remember,
uh,
well several people that have women of a
certain age or a look or they go,
yeah,
but what else?
What else am I going to do?
I'm going to suck Dick for a living.
I'm going to go out on the street and
you go,
you couldn't like,
you know ones,
but then you watch like cops or
something.
When you see a lady like that,
it's getting caught in a pickup truck.
Stuck in some old dudes,
Dick and you go.
I guess you could.
You could.
She could.
So you could.
She's empowering to women is what I'm
saying.
It entirely depends with the Mail on how
horny you are because if your crazy
horny,
I've done some bad things.
We'll do some terrible things.
Were monsters,
bad bad animals.
It's a bad design.
The design where you have to get rid of
them all the time is terrible.
Design.
It would be way better.
I do a lot.
It's an old bit of yours that I quote a
lot is you're a post come depression.
Is that how it goes?
A postnet depression.
Yeah.
That feeling that which is so like I,
I really believed I liked her.
Yes.
Wasn't until.
Oh,
and as the semen as rifling out of you,
you go,
oh,
I misled her.
Oh my God.
I misled myself.
Which that's where you get scared with
the me too thing.
I know I didn't rape anyone,
but how many times might I have led a
woman astray with promises of
everlasting love and harmony just
because I was drunk and wanted to fuck
her and then didn't call.
I was inappropriate afterwards.
I didn't do the,
hey,
um,
I don't think we're right for each other
and she's stewing about it somewhere and
wants are you can't meet to me.
It definitely can happen like that.
Right?
It's like you got to leave room for all
possibilities because I think that to
trust everyone that comes forward with a
story like you shouldn't.
What?
You should be open minded about all the
points of view.
Like I would,
I'd hate to see someone get in trouble
for something they didn't do because
they dated a gal and she hated them and
so she made up some stuff and this has
happened before.
Oh,
absolutely.
People,
you've got to be.
Let me give you an example.
Please do.
How many.
Maybe we should clarify because this is
a touchy subject.
No,
I know you're not a sexist by any
imagination in support of the alleged
witch hunt because it is making people
who are serious abusers and there's one
I fucking want to out but I don't have
to,
but it's not going to be,
you know,
that it's real and then you know that
people in positions of power like that
to have people working under them are
dependent upon them in that way.
They will prey on them and do weird shit
to them and they've been doing it
forever because they can get away with
it and that seems to be like,
that seems to be how this town in a lot
of ways was designed how the whole porn
industry was set up.
But you have to.
There's a willingness on both sides.
Hopefully.
Well,
I think that there's a lot of girls that
will fuck you for a part.
I don't think it's that.
See,
that's not the thing.
It's not like,
um,
again,
there's a million.
The me to encapture encapsulates a lot
of different stages of sexual abuse
variances from.
I always like to think of it.
I have a sister mother rule,
especially as I've gotten older,
like a thought about this for so long
and I feel like you have to treat every,
like if you're in any,
you have to look at every situation.
Like what would that be like?
If I found out that happened to my
mother,
what would that be like if I found out
that happened to my sister.
I mean if you go to children then it
gets really crazy and you get super
psychotic and because your protective as
well.
Although I'm
very protective of my sister,
you get that.
You got to almost look at it like that
and I don't think we get taught that
enough.
You know?
I think it takes us a long time of
living as an adult to sort of figure out
like who's the Dick here?
Is it me or is it them?
Or is it my making bad choices?
Am I arguing with people and getting
these weird relationships with people
that I really don't belong with in the
first place.
Maybe I need to figure out who the fuck
I am before I do this.
Like there's all these different things
that happen in a relationship and a lot
of times along the way people get into
some know,
some weird spaces in their life,
you know,
man show the secretary that we had,
you weren't around for a lot of it
because you were doing.
Unfortunately I work 14 hours a day.
Then man,
shelf for four hours.
They need to do an hour at the comedy
store for 30 minutes about her.
But no,
we didn't know what you gonna sell it.
I'm just like the amount that we abused
or on what we would think is a comedy
level.
Me and Andy,
not you,
you weren't there,
but do it back to you guys too.
But if it was on paper,
but if she had a change of heart right
now and said,
oh,
I want to be part of the me too thing
and here's my story because I want to be
noticed.
You can't do it to me because I'm not
famous fortunately.
Do you think this is one of those like
swing one way and then swing back and
normalize things or do you think that
this.
But I think it might be,
but as time goes on,
I wonder if I just,
this is,
and this is not,
is not saying anything like in,
in any way,
uh,
I don't want to be judgmental,
but I have a weird idea that men,
women,
when they're working together in small
boxes for long periods of time,
year on year,
that becomes their environment.
And that becomes the way they think
about the outside world.
This is us.
This is really important because in
comedy,
the man shall remember we had to do
sexual harassment training.
Yeah.
For a show that's basically about sexual
harassment.
And it was.
But in comedy,
yeah,
we think that we can get away with all
this shit.
So I find myself extrapolating that on a
people that are in a workplace,
I don't know what it's like to work in
an office where the boss says,
Hey,
you can move up to assistant regional
director if you watch me jerk off.
And that's a different thing.
And it's,
that's a real problem.
And the man is the only time I've kind
of hit like the corporate world,
cross corners of comedy meets corporate
where he is.
Someone might be in the story I have in
here that I couldn't have known when we
turn this book in final draft that this
current climate would exist.
So.
So there's a bunch of stories.
Where do you remember mandic?
What was the mandate waves?
I get a assistant producer,
director guy.
He was one that we all fucking hated.
He was just a ruthless Douche.
And then when we went up to.
This is the story that's in the book at
the Bunny Ranch and Dennis Hoff tells us
both,
hey,
you can have one of my girls on the
house.
Carrot top is fucked my girls so and so
is fucked my girls.
And rogue is like A.
First of all,
not only am I married,
but I wouldn't want to be in that litany
of names that you dropped that of other
celebrities that have fucked your
hookers.
He's like,
no,
I wouldn't drop your name.
We played
pretty women.
Remember that?
Pretty woman for those ladies that
worked there.
Oh,
well that was the gag we did.
No,
I don't remember anything.
We did the match.
It was weird.
It bummed me out because like they were
crying and some of them wouldn't montage
that they wished that that had been the
case and that someone would come and
rescue them.
I was like,
God damn it.
Like this isn't funny.
Yeah,
turn now.
I remember it.
Now that you say it,
dude,
for me man.
I was like,
Oh God.
You almost like,
I,
uh,
I've adopted a lot of dogs in my life,
you know,
and I've taken on a lot of friend
projects,
especially when I was young that enough
things have happened that lead me to
believe that I have a lot of like a
rescue in parenting type feelings about
nurturing people that feel like they're
in danger by themselves now.
Very vulnerable.
So when I see something like that and
I'm like,
Oh,
Christ,
you know,
I just,
you realize you don't,
you don't really realize because you
know,
you don't see their lives on a daily
basis,
but you realize in that moment you're
like,
oh,
this isn't funny at all.
And you know,
there's no way to like you think things
are funny on paper,
like you think,
ah,
this is going to be funny.
We'll show a bunch of prostitutes a
video about a lady who was prostitution
going,
white guy,
the perfect guy.
And then they fell in love and it worked
out.
He rescued her man Dick.
I don't remember that.
He's,
he was an assistant.
He was in charge enough that he absolute
power corrupts absolutely.
While he was an absolutely powerful,
but he was absolutely fucking annoying
and we didn't like him,
but I still have this offer on the
table.
They're wrapping up the shoot the last
night.
They're picking up all the equipment.
I'm talking to air force amy,
who's this veteran.
Hilarious hookers who's been there.
Yeah,
she fucking carried me through that
whole thing.
We just sit and drink at the bar and
laugh at everything.
Inappropriate and talk shit.
And I go,
hey,
we get this freebie from Dennis Hoff.
I know he's going to have to pay you.
So,
uh,
how about I just a jerk off in front of
you while you deldot yourself.
You get paid.
We come back to the bar.
Yeah.
Great.
She's Deldot at herself.
I dark gfe come back to.
I come out of the room,
which is right around the corner from
the.
I'm covered in a t shirt with my own
ges.
All I need to do is wait to find
wardrobe.
I get a new t shirt.
I walk out.
This guy that we hate is wrapping up.
He's walking up the stairs as I'm
walking down the stairs to the bar and I
go mandate.
Great.
Shoot.
Good hair.
Fucking hug it in and I hug him in front
of all these people at the bar.
Who knows?
I just jerked and I'm smearing it into
an illegal.
Yeah,
I've done it.
That's a me too.
That guys from the corporate world.
I smeared them with just to humiliate
him.
Oh my God.
How fucking wrong could I like,
it's terrible.
I shouldn't be completely outed for made
this up.
I'd send the book,
but I hope I'm selling the whole book of
Hashtag [inaudible] first.
Not me too.
Interesting.
I,
uh,
I want to say that this last piece by Mr
Doug Stanhope was fiction and A.
Well,
I had to change his name.
So it was a nickname man who was telling
me that,
uh,
trump's lawyer said that he tweeted for
trump.
Trump said something that was fucked up.
Trump's lawyer was like,
no,
no.
I tweeted that one for him.
Oh,
alright.
I've been getting a lot of tweets that
say,
Hey,
my lawyer wrote that,
and I'm like,
I don't know.
I didn't know what it meant is.
Come on.
How fucking funny is that?
I have,
I have a whole chapter about pulling my
dick out.
I used to do that all the time.
I'd go on stage naked or pull my dick.
I remember those days.
Yeah,
the dark days I was,
I was thinner than.
So I just have a different meaning.
I gave him a bunch of pictures,
Hennigan here,
the,
the Scotsman I pulled out.
I pulled my dick out in front of Bert
Kreischer on a podcast two nights ago.
I can't remember.
I can't remember why we were so fucked.
I've been begging him not to air it
because I don't know what I said,
but I've seen Ari's Dick About 100 times
what?
So for the book I sent a bunch of
pictures with Hennigan to pick and
choose and then they took all these dick
pics of me in public and I'm like,
you can't have all the picture section,
just my Dick.
So I had to decide.
So this one I decided on this not having
any idea it could be so perfectly timed.
The top one is me with my dick out in a
kilt in front of a blind guy at Karaoke
while he's singing,
having no idea,
but the one below it is me starting to
pull my dick out in front of Louis.
Oh my jerk off in front of the abusers.
Wow.
Did you find crime?
I didn't have to block the door.
He didn't block the door folks,
by the way,
that's not.
That's not real.
Apparently.
That's like something that like gets
passed on.
Like an urban myth that juices up the
story.
I'm saving this for tomorrow.
I'm doing a dork forest with Jackie
cation and Lori Kilmartin,
so I'm saving the bulk of my Lori,
my Louis C K for that,
just because they are ladies I want.
There are going solid opinion,
but I,
I'm,
I have to make this so spacious timewise
because I don't want to out the person,
but
I was doing comedy and I was a comedian.
I knew back in the day when we were
young in another millennium,
just blame it on Brown.
She said,
you're never going to guess what I just
did.
I just watched Louis C K jerk off in the
ladies room and I went,
why don't she goes,
yeah.
He said,
Hey,
would you?
She's like,
I don't care.
And as we've caught up many,
many years later,
she goes,
yeah,
I just did it because it was funny.
I really,
I did it because it was a story to tell
and I said,
you coming forward.
Because afterwards when she said what
she told me that I go,
you never watched me jerk off.
Got To watch the beach or I pull my dick
out and put on for this.
You Watch,
you watch.
No,
she just said,
yeah,
I don't care.
Whatever.
She like.
It's no fun if you don't watch.
The way I remember it is that she
remembers me saying,
if you don't like it,
don't look either way.
It was just a goof.
She were.
I think you have to stand up to.
I think what we should do to normalize
this whole.
Luis,
hang on.
This is the important part of this is
when I said,
are you going to come out?
She can't because she just did it
because it was funny of course,
and she would almost be putting a place
where she would be as it's people like
you that made him into a monster.
We're just kind of a goof back that no
one cared.
It's only weird and it was very polite.
So when I heard the Louis ck stories
later on,
I just assumed it was like that.
He was very polite.
Hey,
would you watch me jerk off?
Well,
I had heard from someone else that I had
talked to someone who had gotten the
story from Louis and the version of it
through the grape vine.
So don't take this as like verbatim was
something along the lines of.
No,
it was just,
he thought it was silly to like pull his
dick out and take pictures with them and
that I had heard that he was saying that
it wasn't,
he didn't actually masturbate in front
of them.
That was like one version of it.
So I was like,
okay,
well maybe that what?
And then the full story came out and I
went,
oh okay.
And then someone had said,
yeah,
but he asked them first.
I was like,
Oh boy,
what are we doing with this?
This is another important beat is my
story happened before he was in any
position of power other than comics
looked up to him.
He was still writing for comics that
might've had some power at at best.
I think it was a power thing.
If you're a man and you have your alone
in a room with a woman,
and this is my perception of it.
It's always a power thing because it's
fucking weird because you can kill them.
It's different.
Like have you ever been around like a
UFC athletes on big giant?
This was a place where you go,
if you,
if this was a tinder date,
this happened in a place where you'd go,
I want to meet you in public,
so don't want to be.
So yeah,
it was completely safe.
Yeah,
but if.
But if you're alone in a room with a
man,
it's like being an,
you know that a
man has some sexual urges directed
towards you and you're a woman.
It becomes a vulnerable situation and if
there's some weird shit where someone.
If let's say someone was blocking the
door because I had heard that Louis
didn't block any doors,
then it becomes really crazy.
Like what do you do?
Well,
first of all,
you're hearing.
Yes.
Yeah.
Well it's also like I think the thing
that people have the hardest time with
all of this is you never want to think
that it's possible that someone would do
something horrible to somebody if you
like them.
Right?
Like with all of this,
with any of the,
whether it's Kevin Spacey or any of
these people,
like maybe you liked him as an actor.
I like that guy.
He's great on house of cards.
Wait a minute,
is you really just terrorizing people
and grabbing dicks everywhere?
Shit.
Yeah.
I keep people around time.
I do too.
I still grab ass and Dick's.
Oh,
that's not what I do,
but no,
I think about it that way at my house
when.
Oh,
when you guys.
We had a party the other night.
I go,
who have I not got groped in
appropriately.
Okay.
Wait,
Gill,
I haven't done it to you and I grabbed
his dick just to make sure that we're
all fucking good.
Never groped me.
I'm starting to feel a little left out.
I don't think nothing.
I don't even think you've ever gotten
from my,
but I might've googled it from afar.
I think you might have spanked me once,
but the point being it's like,
come on,
we gotta just people have to figure out
some way to interface with each other
100 percent of the time as equal and
just work on your own bullshit,
but when the way you talk to people,
like somebody brought this up once that
they initially with a lot of this stuff
is that it's someone in the same
business that's in this position of
being a great artist like Kevin Spacey
type character or whatever,
and then the other person is like a pa
or something like that and he prays on
them and it's his show and they can't
get away and he's like attacking them.
They're straight and these gay.
Absolutely.
I know that 100 percent.
I think that's some weird,
almost like reptilian instinct that
humans can't tell you how many times
we've had to because you know my
audience overserved quite a bit of the
time and when it's a girl that's alone
and you can see the packs of guys.
Oh good.
Do.
I'll give you a ride.
Where do you live?
Exactly.
All right.
Let's get her an uber because I know
that's going to go poorly and you know
it's fucked up about that.
Here's what's really fucked up.
Not only was the woman the like the
vulnerable one when it comes to like the
possibility of violence,
right?
She's also the vulnerable one when it
comes to her reputation because like if
you and like chat.
Yeah,
right.
If you and Bert Kreischer and five dudes
and a girl hops in the car with you and
she decides to suck everybody off and
then you tell the world and someone
leaks her name and they're like,
it hurts her,
but if you get up,
if you're hitchhiking
and you get picked up by six chicks who
decided to below you and film it and put
it on the Internet and you're cracking
jokes and pitching your book,
your book was chicken sucking your Dick.
You're a king.
You're a Goddamn king that's worship you
because they'll throw up a red carpet
down in front of your van.
As you get out and bowed to you as you
climb out,
send.
Another huge issue is how we treat
women.
Being able to guide their own sexuality,
a 100,
that's a big part of what's going on in
raise your daughters in a different way
than you raise your sons and that's why
it's okay for a teacher to fuck a boy
kid.
Right?
Exactly.
And it is.
By the way,
we're won't even say a word.
It should be treated the same.
You should raise your kids to know about
sex.
You know what?
If you raised your daughters,
it's a woman.
I should say this as long as it's a
woman.
If you raised your daughter with the
same openness that you raise your son,
she'd know not to fuck a 35 year old
soccer coach when she's 15 because you
were open.
You told her,
here's the pitfalls of life.
This is what it's about.
Guys are going to try to buck you.
You don't.
You caught all women and I believe it's
as much a parenting problem as anything
else.
It really is fucking fascinating that
you would have no problem if a really
hot teacher fucked your 16 year old son
for really hot woman teacher like built
like Pamela Anderson back in the
Baywatch days if somehow they teach it.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah,
you should be a little more
discriminating.
But if it was a hot one,
you have no problem with it.
Some Pamela Anderson,
like Gao is having sex with your 17 year
old boy and he's got a six pack.
Yeah,
fuck.
You have Tommy who were a winner.
But if you reverse the genders,
it's a horrific offense.
Like some handsome man has reduced your
beautiful little daughter who's only 17.
Fuck.
That guy needs to be in a cage.
Appeared that,
that alone is like,
this is where I can't extend the
argument because I've never been a
woman.
That's true.
Uh,
and that's why I've been meaning to talk
to you about saving a lot of this for a
while.
I have hosts can a comeback.
Do you remember when we were going to
get married?
Yeah.
That was the last call I'm going to get
married.
I don't know if that's in the book or
not.
The last call I made when we knew the
man show is going to get canceled.
They wouldn't.
That might be in the book.
I think it is.
They,
uh,
the last call I made,
they wouldn't tell us it's canceled.
They leave you hanging on the vine.
But,
uh,
I was at the Atlanta punchline and I
remember being in the parking lot and
Massachusetts had just passed gay
marriage or civil unions,
or maybe you called me up.
I called Zoe Friedman first.
Zoe Friedman was called Zoiah before he
checked on me.
Maybe I called you first,
but she's the one that counted because
she was our goto person at comedy
central.
And I said,
listen,
before you us,
give us one last episode where Jo and I
get gay married and it just goes into
this montage,
but it's the opposite of every marriage
cliche where we're fishing together and
no one's arguing,
no one's fighting over the remote.
We're all happy.
We're both happy to be watching the same
thing and it's just a perfect life
together
to imagine that people decided to do
that.
Imagine if they had best friends,
get married as best friends,
like it's nothing sexual in the
contract.
Zero sexual obligation.
It's not sex.
It's like you are getting married as
best friends like for real than Bros
before hoes.
Just stop and think about how many,
not obviously not the current
relationships we're involved in.
We would never go so far,
but if you go back to like your
twenties,
just imagine being stuck with some gap
when you're both God damn wreck,
right?
You're both crazy.
You're both 21 or whatever the fuck you.
Are.
You both completely out of your mind.
You're basically babies alone in the
world.
You don't know what the fuck you're
doing.
Imagine living with that Gal for the
rest of your life versus your friend
from back then.
I'm still friends with my buddies from
when I was 21,
Jimmy lawless.
I talked to that dude all the time.
We text each other back and forth all
the time.
I've been friends with him since I was
15 or 14.
I might've been 14 when I met him.
I don't know.
Doug.
I hate your cigarette smoke during the
podcast.
A.
Okay.
I'll put in a a air purifier
and that's the beef.
That's our marriage beef.
This is our meat.
This is something I really did.
I call it the dice clay option because
die every time diocese here,
he chain smokes more than you and dice
just hammers.
We got an air cleaner that we would sit
right behind him and turn that thing on
just to suck out the cigarette smoke
because it's either that the air
purifiers belching sewage by the second
hour is just brown tar.
Well,
he's the guy that to this day I still
fan boy in front of.
I can't believe I'm friends with dice
clay like a really can't.
Every time I see him I'm like,
he's up to feel like you're friends with
them.
Like I've.
I've only met him a few times,
but I never saw like a human side to
him.
He's always been anthony.
He's in character.
You can get there with them.
I don't want to,
I don't want to see him like that.
He's a good guy,
man.
I don't want to see the emperor with no
clothes.
His clothes are still on.
I'm telling you.
It's all right.
He's just a guy that's like,
you know,
dice clay was gigantic and he got hit
with the first wave of comedy haters.
Like people don't remember what I was
19.
It was me and my girlfriend Marta,
and we were parked out in front of my
house and we were listening to a dice
clay cassette in my car and we were
fucking crying.
I mean,
tears are coming down my face.
I was 19,
I think she was 19 too.
We were both like,
yeah.
Ah,
ah,
ah.
Never
even considered doing standup at this
point just so I was dying laughing.
He's the reason I got into Stanford.
He was a monster.
And he was telling Rena he was coming
off the whole wave of Paul Riser.
Yes.
There was no backlash.
We already noticed.
Thanks Jennifer.
Notice rather,
fuck you.
Paul Riser is amazing on stranger
things.
Uh,
he's amazing.
You should fucking kids.
Demagogue.
Oregon's what?
Exactly.
Don't know.
You have no demagogue and knowledge on
the fucker talking out your ass.
I tried,
I want to say about stranger things.
I watched five minutes of the first one
and I'm like,
I can't watch kids and fuck it.
It looked like that.
It gets better.
It gets so good.
It's such a good show.
How dare you try to fail.
I'm gonna.
Hey,
can you see,
I hate to use my,
a scotsman as a,
a errand boy.
Is there a coke in there?
Tried to find them.
I'm not.
I don't think so.
There's some,
there might be a.
nevermind Kansas Divia go in there,
motherfucker.
Come on.
It sounds like it's gone.
Fucking something in it.
No,
it's okay.
Brian,
he left.
Sorry.
I think there's like one can as eva.
He [inaudible] it sounds like it has
stevia.
Yay.
Fuck that.
No Way.
Can we,
um,
the first cans of coke?
I just assumed.
No,
I brought whiskey because I assumed he
wouldn't have club soda.
So,
uh,
I thought if I'm going to have a vodka
drink,
I'll just drink mimosas.
I'm fine.
That's a good move.
We can have some God for me.
Oh No,
I don't need.
I know.
I just assumed everyone has tried to
work our way through this whole
experience here at this new spot.
We're not totally locked into place.
If you want some unhealthy options,
I'll have some gluten heavy pasta.
I have plenty of.
I was going to change up.
I'm not going to you.
Here's what we'll do next time you come
here.
I will have my nonexistent assistant
send you an email with like a,
a ride.
You don't want to run like a writer,
like white m's.
No,
no,
no.
It's good.
Stevia.
Stevia is a good dude.
They're good and Italian.
You just give it a chance.
So it's awful.
No,
no.
Sugar is fake.
Show that it's not.
It's a plan already.
Son of a coach.
Bingo takes the Stevia all the fucking
time.
But these sodas are good,
man.
I'm telling you,
they're really good and they're not
going to kill your sugar.
Leaves such a bad taste in your mouth
and I can't taste anything after 35
years of smoking plant extracts.
It's a sweet thing that doesn't Jack up
your glycemic index.
It's good for you,
Bro.
Send me to stay alive.
Hannegan that you sent me.
Just so you can talk about me.
Not One handling has been dealing with
subterfuge.
It's no fun talking behind your back
when we can do it to your face.
Hennigan,
enjoy.
He's one of the things I enjoy about you
is you are very self deprecating fellow
who is.
You are.
You could take a good jab.
Yeah.
And you give one back.
Yes.
Cheers to that.
Thank you.
Is that a Scottish thing?
Seemed it seemed a little bit more fun
over there.
I would say the sculpt so good at being
self deprecating and calling.
I couldn't come.
Yeah.
And your billy connolly.
He was like the main guy over there as
far as standup and he.
That was his whole thing.
He embodied that.
Yeah,
just happy dude.
Thing is a big thing in Scottish
society,
which means one of the few good things
I'll save her scholarship society is
it's kind of egalitarian and we enjoy
knocking.
People don't who think they're better
than other people,
including yourself.
Australians do that shit too.
They call it the tall poppy syndrome and
Japan.
Yeah,
I think it's good,
man.
Good.
You know what I mean?
I think that's one of the things.
We're also going to always be 100
percent and it goes back to your thing
about punching up.
Not yet occasionally,
because here's the thing about this
whole punching up,
punching down thing.
I always bring up Sam Kennison bit about
the Ethiopian kids that were starving to
death.
It's one of the fucking greatest all
time bits and it's all hundred percent
punching down.
He's got to,
in my opinion,
I mean if you have a list of the
greatest of all time bits to have them
in my mind or Sam Kennison and one of
them was the Ethiopian kids was like,
you know,
you're sitting at home,
you got a dinner,
you made it out yourself.
You know,
you're sitting in front of the TV,
feel good about life and all of a sudden
this fucking kid is starving kid and
there's a guy right next to them like,
could you please just give a couple
dollars a month?
So this guy goes,
hey,
and you're like,
why don't.
Why don't you feed them?
You're right next to them.
I think it was.
I all I remember from that bit is send a
moving trucks.
You.
The way the food is.
Yeah.
He goes deserts in America to which it
was chaos because it was the most
punching down bit of all time.
Starving children in Ethiopia.
I don't think that's punching.
Punching at the people that are selling
you this as you're grabbing the little
Ethiopian by,
Hey,
come here,
come here motherfucker.
Collateral damage.
Going to 100 years now.
Fucking punching down.
I was talking about specifically twitter
fights were like Christine Levine,
who's at a Mammo,
she's a friend of mine.
She opens for me quite as her name Malmo
is that.
That was her nickname when I met her
online.
I know so many people based on their
twitter name phase back in the day,
well before that were a Icq.
What does that.
She.
She's a,
she's a,
what does that fucking text Iq?
I remember that Shit.
I was,
I was doing the dot comedy dot standup.
Didn't find the ICQ,
but uh,
there's something freeing about being
able to talk to someone.
You don't know what the fuck they look
like.
They don't know what the fuck you look
You can just chat with each other
online.
Something freeing about that.
Yeah.
You know,
you like,
you get to know people just for the
information.
I just know that you're annoying.
It has nothing to do with your
sexuality,
your race,
your religion.
I just know you're annoying as a human
being and you realized that I judged you
for no other reason than you.
And some people will trickier,
but some people,
you meet them online and they turn out
to be the exact same thing when you meet
her in person and they're really cool.
I've met some of the funniest people,
Funny Online,
funny that when you meet them,
biggest social retards that they can't
have or can't make eye contact,
can't deliver the law if they're on the
keyboard.
They're the funniest person.
They just have no social skills.
They can't present themselves.
Right.
This guy is funnier than me.
Await in real life.
No,
he's not.
He could never do what we do,
but he could write from a in a dark
room.
This is chick
that is unbelievably hilarious on
twitter and I found a recently.
What is it?
Nacho.
Sarah.
What is,
what is?
Yes,
what is that,
Jill?
Sarah.
But I think that's her twitter handle.
Dude.
She's fucking hilarious.
Like I'll go to her like every two,
three days.
I'll just go and check her twitter page
just to see what ridiculous shit she
posts.
She's really fucking funny and I'm like,
are you a standup?
Like.
And she's like,
well,
I tried to wants,
but you know,
you know who I because are right.
They're not.
Joe.
Sarah
said,
this is the same problem I have with my,
uh,
twitter crush is Laura Duck.
The one arm girl.
Okay.
Yeah.
She,
she made kind of national news,
twitter at national news because she put
on her tinder.
She's an arms dealer.
She had just lost her arm.
Laura or Lauren Duck,
a duck fan is the twitter account duck
fans up there?
Uh,
and she,
yeah,
she,
she got her arm lopped off by a train
and she posts also.
It's as somebody shit.
But she also posts really funny shit.
And I said,
I wish when I come to San Diego that you
had a set because you're hot,
you have one arm,
everything's already in your favor.
You're already naturally funny.
Yeah.
There's some fucking funny people on
tour.
There's some funny people that work at
the post office.
They just don't get a chance to like the
idea that we have figured out a way to
monetize.
The way we look at things is so
offensive.
It's so fast.
There's so many people in so many jobs,
so they're just as funny as us.
They or maybe way more like my friend
Dave Dolan,
rest in peace who is one of my bosses
back when I was first starting doing
standup,
he was a private investigator.
Funniest person I've ever met in my life
right next to Joe eps.
He's like right up there.
He was.
He was a private investigator and I
worked for him because he got caught in
a Dui,
needed a driver,
so he put an ad in a for an assistant
for a private investigator and I was
looking for a day job while I was doing
standup at nine.
It was like perfect assistant for a
private investigator,
this God damn comic books and so I
started working for this guy and he's
this crazy Irish private investigator.
Wild Man.
I mean,
he's a fucking wild man.
He was so funny and he would just tell
me stories about nutty,
shitty did and crazy fucking girls.
He knew and you know,
just just.
I would be in my car crying,
laughing,
waiting for this person to come.
We'd be at like 5:00
in the morning parked like doing like
surveillance on someone's house,
like waiting for them to leave their
house at 5:00
in the morning if someone's like doing
like some sort of insecurity scam.
Mostly it was insurance and he would
just.
I would be crying and I was thinking I'm
trying to be a comic.
This guys five,
six years older than me at least like
maybe nine years older than me.
I think I was 20 and was like 30.
Is it an attorney?
The attorney,
he was an animal.
I mean he was so fucking funny and I was
like,
I'll never be as funny as him.
I just will never be as funny as him.
Like this is depressing.
I loved working for the guy and I worked
for him for the entire six months that
he needed to have no license after he
got arrested for a Dui.
Stayed friends and I love that guy.
In the book I talk about Becker and
Andy,
like two guys that are way funnier than
me and a fuck them.
They never could put it together on
stage.
I want to be as much as they say,
they're trying to be like you.
I'm trying to be like them.
Right.
You know those funny people,
you know?
Yeah.
I want,
I want to steal that essence because I
know how to put it on stage.
Never be naturally off the cuff as funny
as the funniest people I've met,
but I can do it on stage and you can't,
so fuck you.
Uh,
that's ruthless.
I can,
I can boil down the organization.
There's some sort of writer
correspondent he should have.
You should have a policy that sexual
harassment is mandatory and everybody
works inside the Doug Stan Hope.
Information Collection Organization like
anybody's trying to help you with the
creation of your act idea gathering.
What have you.
It was an unspoken each other until now.
No,
it's kind of the thing and that's why we
were talking about the no one's meet
doing rock and roll bands.
Like they're not pulling led Zeppelin's
library off of itunes because they
fucked,
fucked a girl with a fish.
But here's my.
When you walk into the backstage area at
a rock'n'roll concert,
there's an unwritten rule.
Yeah,
the,
the roadie tapped you on the shoulder
for a reason and you know what the
reason is I was made to feel
uncomfortable.
He pulled out his dick out of sweaty
leather pants after the show underwear.
No underwear.
And then girls were bumps off
of it.
No,
they were gunners mostly because of the
ball sweat a governors.
I understand there's a difference
between that and what happens with
fucking Harvey Weinstein.
That's a fucking rapist.
Yes.
One hundred percent.
And here's the part,
part of the problem is that what we were
talking about earlier,
that if you got in a car with seven
women and they all fuck you,
you're a hero,
would have a gal gets in the car with
seven.
Jason Mamoa was that uh,
the guy from the game of thrones,
that fucking beautiful handsome man,
that gigantic cancer man,
he's so huge and so beautiful,
like have seven of those were in a car
and it was a gal and she was just like
ravaged,
and she's some sort of a damage thing.
We know those,
we know those girls that celebrate that.
No,
no.
We know the ones that are like,
yeah,
I fucked that guy.
I know a few.
Yeah,
for sure.
That are just like,
dudes.
You shouldn't be like that for
everybody.
It's a suppression issue.
It's the same reason why Catholics feel
guilty.
It's not a matter of why what's wrong or
what's right.
It's a matter of what you enjoy and what
you don't enjoy it because other people
are going to judge you for it and then
you've got to get to the root of why
these people judging it for a giant
percentage of the men that judge women
for their sexual activity.
It's 100 percent out of jealousy,
so 100 percent out of the idea that this
woman would not want to do that with
them and they cast a judgement on her
and they decided that her needs are
different than our than the demands
needs,
but the bottom line is all these things
were established back when it was really
difficult to have children and you had
to protect your children and most of
them are going to die and you were
literally concerned about the population
of your village.
Well,
those instincts,
they still exist,
but the problem is that's not a concern
anymore and then this fucking birth
control and whatever,
19,
60,
whatever.
That chick came out.
When did that come out?
When the chick start being superheroes
was a early seventies when roe versus
Wade and control and all that.
Yeah,
it should be even,
you know,
there's,
there's gotta be some sort of a way to
make it even easier than all this has
gotta be a way where you let the natural
hormones will think what has happened is
60 and nailed it to nailed it.
I think it did.
Nineteen 60.
I thought were going to make the
argument for bringing back villages.
Well,
it's not a bad idea,
man.
Here's the thing.
I think cities are amazing,
but I don't think we're designed for it
and I think we will be ready for it and
a couple hundred years it's going to
take some sort of an adaptation to the
human psyche and the way we interact
with each other,
but I think it's totally doable if
people like us can do it.
This is how I've always felt.
If the entire world was the four of us
in this room,
we will be fine.
Like what if we were the only people
with what if we were immortal?
We didn't have to worry about dying and
it was just the four of us and it just a
bunch of food and shit to do.
Do you think we would have any problem
at all?
Yeah,
we would miss the fact that we're in.
He checks.
That'd be kind of a bummer,
but we would probably have a good time.
We just had unlimited resources,
Roman around,
which we do.
Yeah.
Well,
essentially the,
the,
the world like wildfire in Ventura
spreads
across the world while this podcast goes
on and on,
and then we walk out and you're like,
oh,
fucking Zombie apocalypse without the
zombies.
The zombies kicking into that of ashes
sent those on the grill.
They showed us how to use it could press
buttons and I'm going to have to drink
stevia.
I'll,
I'll get irritated by that.
Just do me a favor.
Give them a little.
No,
no,
I've,
I've done it.
You're racist.
Just try it.
I don't know if it's hot in here,
but I'm actually sweating from the gears
and I thought it's because Joe Rogan's
bellowing so much.
I'm bleeding out of my earphones.
Sorry,
but it's actually sweat.
I'm sweating on your earphones and
whoever sits here next.
I hope he's OCD because.
Are you a just leapt up.
Fire it up.
I'm trying to be too loud.
No,
no,
no one was giving me shit.
I know.
I just never know when you're being
real.
No,
no.
I am sweating from my earphones and I
think that's gross that I'm sweating on
your earphone so I had to say it.
I don't give a fuck dude.
I don't give a fuck about period blood.
I don't give a fuck about sweat.
That bothers me.
I've never seen people do bother me
because I am everything.
I would assume that they find to be a
problem.
I'm filthy.
I think you should eat meat with 30
hands.
That's what I think.
I think you should eat meat with dirty.
If I know someone's OCD,
I'm afraid to be around them.
I'm comfortable.
I have a friend who went to look at a
house and they were looking at the house
and as a nice house like wow,
this house beautiful.
And then they got to this one closet and
the closet was filled with Purell,
with hand sanitizer and they went,
fuck this.
Like this house is haunted my friends.
That dude,
the fucking thing was filled.
It was a closet.
It was filled from the floor all the way
to the top of pure route.
They were like,
you knew stern and ONA.
I don't know if both.
Oh,
and a one of them at least they were all
purell touching everything and if I get
a cold and my,
my guttural smoker's cough is enough
that you're gonna not want me here.
I cough off Mike.
I try to,
but I know he's going to hear it and go.
Think about how many people you interact
with and shake hands with.
I think the more people you share your
biome with,
like Paul stamets,
the mushroom guy,
you know,
he has some pretty famous mycologist
who's on my podcast really recently.
It's amazing stories,
but one of the things that he said is
like if you come in contact with
someone,
their biome interacts with your biome
and you,
there's a,
some sort of a residual amount of DNA
that you're taking into your own biome.
Like,
like if you meet somebody,
you become part of them and some very
bizarre way.
I was like,
what?
He's like intro,
introduce in like,
you know,
welcome to my home,
and I was like,
this is crazy.
Welcome to my.
He's a scientist so he's not like just
bullshitting and he's not like some
crazy dude who doesn't believe in birds.
Go on it.
You told me something on a podcast years
ago and it's one of those things that
comes up late at night where I go,
I want to call Rogan,
but I'm not going to call you at 1130 at
night.
And what was the thing that you said?
Listen,
call me anytime you call me.
You want to call me,
call me please.
I don't bother you.
You can see.
Do you see love to use a quote from you
on the back of this book?
No,
no,
I called people that if they said no,
we're not friends.
Anyway,
Chris Rock said No.
Well I don't know him.
Anyway,
he's a nice guy.
I know he is.
He wrote me a better quote.
He then I would have.
I would love to quote your book,
man.
Don't ever asked me.
I mean don't ever worry about asking me.
I don't want to put anyone on the spot.
I'll put me on the spot.
I love you.
You,
you had one of my favorite people.
If I have a top 20 people that survived
and everybody dies,
you're in like if there was like some
sort of an apocalypse though,
we'll work on it with a side.
He gained like five of year free.
So I got five of mind family,
whoever need to know this still alive.
You told me something about over the
course of I think 20 years,
the amount of uh,
of cells.
You're not even the same person you were
seven years.
Tell it with your smart way of saying
it.
I'm,
by the way,
this is like third hand smart way
because I'm clearly a retard,
but if you go back to like seven years
ago and then today you literally don't
have the same cells in most of your
body.
The only thing that doesn't regenerate
as the neurons,
the neurons do not regenerate,
but every cell in your body is different
than the cells in your body from seven
years ago.
So what are your memories remain?
And this is part of the problem.
It's become you become a victim to the
momentum of your past behavior and
there's nothing you can do about it.
So if you're Kevin Spacey,
you decided six months ago,
I am not grabbing any more dicks.
I'm fucking done with this.
I'm going to be a better person.
Like you are attached the momentum of
your past behavior.
You know,
no matter what,
even if you're not even that guy
anymore,
like seven years later,
you wake up,
you wake up in the morning,
shit,
what did I grab?
Grab some decks.
Fuck,
why did I do that?
Granted,
God dammit.
Oh,
I was so drunk.
That's something you can do.
You're stuck with that idea like we
have,
we have to get past that.
We have to figure out a way.
I think Pi,
they have to take those electric things
and fucking change your brain.
Like she like shock therapy and then
we'll let you ride when you don't
account for growth and that.
This is my huge thing.
If I had a,
uh,
a charity that I was behind,
if I was on dancing with the stars,
which think is going to be in those
negotiations were going on in.
Remember,
listen,
don't you killed Doug Stanhope.
I had a fucking Dina since pot seen
before men.
Uneasy.
He wants to die by the innocence
project.
Let me,
let me,
let me get this point out.
And then let's go back to dancing with
Joe Innocence project.
That's my thing.
And uh,
I don't,
I've never been locked up when I was
innocent.
It's just,
it's my fear.
And when you terrifying fear of the
entire prison system,
the justice system,
the prison doesn't work whatsoever.
And when you lock someone up at 18 years
old for some shit you,
you,
you grow out of these things,
like you're not accepting that as you
age,
you rethink things and you're,
it's full.
It's totally ineffective way to reform
people as well.
Most prisons,
some prisons are trying to be more
progressive with their scandinavia.
Iceland,
yes.
Mostly outside of America.
America has a real problem and one of
the real problems is there's not all of
it,
but a certain amount of the press.
Yes.
For profit and these private prison
systems.
Anytime something's for profit,
the system benefits from these laws
being uniform or increasing in severity
and like.
So if you have like a way where people
can profit.
Like this was the issue that I had with
marijuana.
Will you would find out that prison
guard unions would be lobbying against
marijuana for jobs.
Yes.
I'm like,
police having done so well and what are
we like our 45 now.
Not Stepping on my new bits because
that's all I have.
That kind of stuff.
But all of the things we're talking
about.
I was talking about Brian with Brian on
the other day and we were talking about
something and he was like,
you know,
I've been talking about this in my act
and I'm like,
of course you have because this is like
what's really relevant today and I think
that all of us have this weird thing
like we don't want to step on each
other's material and let of course
you're going to see some of the same
things that I'm seeing and I want to see
your take on it as much as I want to see
my take on it.
Oh,
I'm just,
I'm trying not to do punch line as key
to the discourse and not go into bit.
I have to.
I know what you mean.
Yeah,
it's those bits are good,
but you don't want to give them up yet.
No,
no,
and honestly this one bit that goes with
the entire rape thing.
I have been missing just one ceiling
chunk of this bit that's sometimes goes
25 minutes of too long and I just trying
to get the point across and all this
current climate as I keep calling it has
me like that's what I was missing.
Now I have specific examples of this guy
versus this guy now it made the entire
bit come together and now I'm off the
road until March or like motherfucker.
Now I actually want to go out and do
more dates just because this a year and
a half I think I've been working on this
bucket and one stupid bit that happens.
You know Chris Rock said that he was
working on that.
I love black people.
I hate niggers and remember that.
Fuck you.
Who says it?
He wasn't white man doesn't.
It was.
It is in my estimation,
one of the all time greatest,
most significant standup comedy bits
ever and when it hit,
I remember I was just kind of starting
out when that bit was like popular on
that bit was like on cds and people
would play it back and you'd see it on
television.
You'd be like,
I was like,
oh my God.
It's like a perfect bit.
Like he had it boiled down.
The punch lines were so succinct.
It was just Bam,
Bam,
Bam.
And then I read that he had bombed with
that pit for months and months before he
figured out how to get it to work.
I got hate mail from fan.
It's not like agregious actually.
Well thought out.
Hey,
I saw you.
I agree with most of what you say,
but what you were saying,
are you saying?
And I'm like,
no,
that's not what I'm saying.
That's what I'm trying to not say,
but yeah,
I'm having such a hard time alliterating
this and everything that's happened in
the last month or two has,
oh now I can exactly point out what I'm
saying.
And I actually have reverse engineered
it where I go,
oh,
I shouldn't be starting from where I was
ending and then go the other way rather
than apologizing and yeah.
Yeah.
Well it's been boarded out right when I
get off the road fucking asshole.
But you'll,
it doesn't matter.
It isn't an always kinda like fucking.
It's,
it keeps going like it's done in a new
branch pops out of the tree and you're
like,
oh,
this is what's going to bear fruit for.
I was doing these shitty gigs for
fucking months and every night I hated
going onstage and now I want to go
onstage,
but I don't have a Gig.
Well,
what I like,
what I've found pretty recently,
like within the last year,
I mean is that that is all like some
shit that I internalize and then if I
can just like it express or,
or respond to that,
the least amount.
Like all the weird shit.
I know it exists.
I have a weird set.
It's too long.
It's too this too that I don't like it.
I know it exists.
Don't,
don't freak out,
but,
but understand what that is and then you
know what that is.
That's it didn't work.
Now let's figure out how to fucking
never let that happen again because
there's a big difference with the swing
between like the audience having a
fucking amazing time or it was really
good for 45 minutes that suck for 10
like shit.
There is no better learning experience
that happens for decades than eating
shit.
Nothing will ever make you know,
come back stronger than actually dying
on your ass.
But I'd rather be mediocre.
But even mediocre like eating shit dude,
I ain't shit after Jim Brewer in some
weird suburb outside of the city in New
York.
I shit so hard.
It changed my life.
Probably not recently.
No.
It was like 93,
maybe [inaudible] 93 and brewer and our
just start now and I was fine.
Like I really shouldn't have been
headlining.
There's no way I should have been
headline.
I had maybe 45 minutes that was mediocre
at best and brewer and I had a great
time all weekend.
Friday two shows everything worked out
great.
But although if I'm being honest,
I want to say that he had better sets,
at least two of the three shows.
At least two of the three shows he had
better sets,
but I had good sets.
It wasn't embarrassing.
And then the second show,
Saturday night he made me eat a bus load
of shit.
I bombed like the one of the wars
bombings ever of my career ever where it
was like everything that came out of my
mouth was a Dr.
brick and he destroyed in front of me.
I mean,
destroyed the program.
Like fucking crumbs.
We're breaking up off of the fucking low
hanging ceiling.
You know that it was,
you know,
those pipes.
Actually I think I,
that's I,
I think I coined that.
It was a like a brick.
The words came out of my mouth like a
brick through a funnel.
It feels like you have a mouthful of
dirt.
The one I talked to the following and I
where I can blame the middle.
Act.
Like sometimes they just don't like you.
The middle I can take credit,
but no,
they just hated you.
The one I couldn't follow for a week in
Miami was Chris Porter,
Chris Porter.
Chris border.
You know Chris Porter?
Yeah.
Fucking stoner.
Fucking thin curly hair.
He's very funny.
But we're Miami Improv at the time.
This was probably 2000 and it was a,
an urban room black.
Well No,
no,
because there was a lot of Cuban too.
So,
but yeah,
maybe five white people that are scared.
Sammy Sosa,
Cuban,
1993 or Sammy Sosa,
2017.
Miami,
Fort Lauderdale,
dark.
Not West Palm.
My girls have lived first night I,
I assumed I am getting fired.
So I just go crazy.
Took on.
No,
no,
no.
I went there throwing fucking empty
cigarette packs at me on stage following
Chris Porter who knew all the fucking
recent hip hoppy things.
He had all the current urban trends in
Zack did he fucking destroyed and I'm up
there like kind of knew with my anti
authoritarian kind of point of view and
fuck,
vice cops have this fuck Nash.
And he closed.
It was right after.
This'll probably dated when it,
cause he was,
it was when France wouldn't let us fly
over their airspace.
Yeah.
If we say this point,
that's the point.
Being years later I got one of my best
bits ever about nationalism out of that
because he closed on fuck France if we
had an to save their ass in two world
wars.
And I turned that eventually in new one
of my best bits ever because I would go
up and I'd follow him going,
yes,
that's right.
Chris bought there.
That was the French coding you.
Yeah.
As Chris bought there,
they're not.
These are not door.
Please help us.
You.
And it turned into that bid I did about
nationalism.
Where if we hadn't saved the French was
at us,
was at us guaranteeing routes in the
trenches and Verdun was that you
wouldn't be.
I remember last night we were hammered.
I don't remember saving the French.
I remember we went through the drive
through without a car.
We did a lot of things,
but we didn't save the French.
You're talking about other people that
did shit and you're taking credit for
it.
Nationalism does nothing but teach you
how to take credit for other people's
accomplishments.
But the same can be said for rooting for
the raiders,
right?
Yeah,
sure.
Fucking warm boom.
Right?
Yeah.
It's a very bizarre thing that we love
to do and I think it's all connected to
the.
Why does home field advantage work?
My fucking best idea.
Affable so uncomfortable in that arena
for all those other people.
It's my best idea that no Billy Ball
kind of people in the professional
sports leagues are picking up on field a
team of sociopath's because homefield
advantage is one of the biggest things
in sports.
Home field advantage.
If you feel the team of sociopath's that
don't care about cheers or booze,
yeah,
there's no home field advantage anymore
because these are psychopaths that don't
care about cheers.
They just want to win and kill.
All right?
That's not sustainable.
You've got to shoot them after a couple
of years,
as soon as they start wearing diamonds
in their watches,
you got to shoot them in the locker room
like what happened?
What happened?
How did he die?
Like W,
W,
w,
Aaron Hernandez,
that guy was a tinder.
May Be eliminating the home team
advantage for NBA players hating on it.
The black man is tinder.
I want you to consider the fact that a
giant percentage of NBA players are
people of color.
You racist fucks.
They're swooping into these white towns
and banging all these white chicks and
you got a problem tender home field
advantage to make it easier for them.
They don't have to go do work.
They just.
I'm sorry.
I sorry,
what?
I say,
come to the hotel instead of having to
go into tinder.
Tinder.
I'm sorry.
I was just doing that for comedy.
Oh my God.
If I was still a sexual being man as a
sexual being,
that's a Bernie Mac and
bad Santa Bernie Mac.
Mac will be hilarious.
Standup.
You ever see Bernie Mac live?
Mm.
No.
I saw Bernie Mac live at the comedy
connection in Boston once and I was
like,
Holy Shit.
He was.
He was a powerful man.
I mean his material was really funny,
but shit,
his delivery was like,
like electric,
like boom,
boom.
And His name of black comedian where you
go.
His material is great,
but as deliveries under sold,
um,
don't say animals.
Got a good delivery.
Get this thing going on.
He's my buddy Franklin Gi.
Oh,
Franklin at giant.
The giant super low key with his
delivery.
Hilarious ideas and met him at the
greenroom.
Paul provenza wished that show is still
on.
Let's do the green room with Doug's
hope.
Well,
podcasting is basically that.
It is that as,
but let's get on showtime for the fuck
of it.
Shit.
So we can call her mom's show time.
Mommy and my mom's data.
I forgot I said that right.
I was.
I was like,
man,
I feel guilty.
Oh,
it's stand up.
Don't have to feel bad.
I will call my grandma.
My grandma's doing bro.
Fucking Chad Shanky just came back from
thanksgiving.
He's like,
uh,
yeah.
I had to go to my grandparents' house.
Does he work for you?
Does he know it's December fifth kind of
fucking bullshit.
Is this?
Does that mean thanksgiving?
Long time ago,
motherfucker this work to be done?
No.
The point of the story was he was
talking about being at Thanksgiving at
his grandparent's house,
who we revered and then how he brought
his kid and his kids.
Kids to globe,
Arizona because he's not a family guy.
Right.
But then I started doing the math,
like you have grandchildren and
grandparents.
That means the kids are going to meet
their great,
great grandparents.
Did you ever meet your great,
great grandparents?
Oh my.
Almost all.
My last grandparent died when I was 13
and both of my grandfathers were dead
before I was born.
My great,
great grandfather on my.
You were alive in the mud.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
I barely remember though.
Super Young.
Really great parents.
Great.
Great grandparents are the people that
built the stone that built this town
before it was a town and this was all
waste water.
Well,
my great,
great grandfather decided to take his
family from Italy to America in the 19.
Well basically draw.
That's right.
Your mom's a Guinea better.
Yeah,
she's full on pop.
Sorry.
Yeah,
she's full on Kenny.
And uh,
my father was half Italian,
half Irish.
The everybody was immigrants though from
my mom's side.
One hundred percent.
My mother,
my mother,
her,
her mother and her father,
both from the old country.
They see.
We don't realize it because we're living
in this weird fucking semi gentrified
starbucks era of 2017.
But just during my parents' time,
people got on boats and they drifted
from Europe across America and these
shitty engines and they landed.
I mean,
it was like fucking decades after the
titanic sank.
These crazy fucks.
They took the wildest chance ever.
They floated across the Goddamn Atlantic
Ocean to look for a better role in gut.
Here on coach.
Hey,
who from southwest?
He was sitting right next to the toilet,
almost had a middle seat,
but he finagled his way out of it to an
aisle.
The boarding
group,
a 15 through 30.
I mean,
this shit just happened.
Our families all just got here.
Even if you're third generation,
that's fucking three generations.
That ain't shit.
It's nothing.
Fourth-Generation fifth,
shut the fuck Mark Burns who have been
here since the 19 hundreds.
Who Know that you just got here.
Everybody just got here.
I live in one of those towns where they,
they,
they love to say,
Oh,
I'm a native.
Like,
that makes you better because you never
left and decided you wanted to be here
as a functioning free thinking.
Adult natives are the first people you
discount was born hero.
You just moved here.
Well,
yeah,
because I was an adult and I decided I
wanted to live here.
You just didn't have the courage to
leave and come back.
Yeah.
Sons of bitches fuck natives.
It's not easy.
It's not even that.
Honestly,
that was a native.
Not Native Americans.
I know what you mean.
They don't know where to go.
They're drunk.
The busy people don't know where to go.
You don't have to go anywhere.
Just make the place better.
But the Vegas Vegas is one of those.
Any city that is a only alive and
thriving because of tourism,
but then they take a stand because I was
born here.
Well,
Vegas,
Hawaii,
Hawaii does it with white people a
little bit,
but it'll knowing why they hate
tourists,
but if it wasn't for tourists,
you're fucking farming pineapples.
Are you finding farming pineapples?
Are you selling crocs somewhere in a
beach resort?
Are you doing massage therapy?
Are you doing chakra healing or are you
farming pineapples?
Because without tourists,
you're farming pineapples and hoping
Captain Cook's descendants come back and
offer you some gifts,
or you're eating fish that you just
caught with a stick and you're trading
money in the form of shells on a string.
Right?
That's okay too.
Like why is bitcoin okay?
But shells aren't good.
How come we can't treat you just paid me
in shells to be here.
Yeah,
that's what I'm going to give you.
Lumps of salt too.
There were little lumps of salt and
chocolate and the chocolate.
Gold coins and ketogenic cookies and
Stevia drinks.
Okay.
Over there.
Let's do some ad copy.
God dammit.
What's up?
Okay,
I'm fine.
Alright buddy.
I want to ask you this headphones.
Hang on.
Joe Rogan was just in right before I
shut off my phone.
Giant.
Now.
Oh yeah,
please order the book.
You know what?
Let's take a minute so people can go
online and order.
Doug Stan hope this is not fame.
It's got awful stories that in the
current climate,
if the publisher read it right now,
they'd go,
we should probably pull this because.
Yeah.
So if you find it folks,
everyone else is getting fired for what
I'm celebrating,
having done worse,
copy it,
copy it down and make sure these
monsters out there.
Don't take it off the Internet.
I have.
I have the.
You have the new beautiful space here.
Thing.
Endless yards and yards of space.
The Wolf,
you have the giant wolf out there.
When you walk in the door there.
Is that a Patrick Mcgee?
Yes.
Goes to ride.
You know Chaley.
Remember when I used to pit my tour
manager against your red band,
Greg.
He's.
Yeah,
he's my guy.
He loves.
I love him.
On Your podcast.
He,
him and his twin brother do that for a
living.
They have their own ghost ride
productions,
which is a huge hot.
They make this shit.
Patrick Mcgee that did your woolf works
for Greg Chili's twin brother.
That's a ghost ride productions if you
want weird shit like that.
Joe Rogan,
I hope you're a loyal sponsor now.
I've only ghost ride productions.
They do all this shit.
Shaylee does the.
He does a haunted house at the in the
front yard in Brisbane.
He does haunted front yard and he brings
all this shit down.
Every Halloween is so geeked up to do
it.
The only thing is maybe I want it to be
one of these guys when I was a kid too.
That was a huge star wars fan to the
point where I wanted to be like a Rick
Baker.
I wanted to do that for a living.
And uh,
Pat Mcgee was on the podcast and we're
both huge fans of an American in London.
That's a biggie.
That's right there.
That right there.
He was on the podcast a few years back
and uh,
I,
I found the American Werewolf in London
that,
that a cop,
what it is,
is a,
it's a replica of the thing that's in
the movie and Pat sells it.
You can order it online and he,
um,
he builds it,
but it's like the real exact scales,
like one and a half times the size,
the real werewolf,
the Werewolf,
a smaller.
My werewolves bigger.
I just texted when we got here today,
I texted a picture that,
that to Chile and he goes,
oh,
that looks like a,
a.
I go,
hey,
how's this for Halloween?
Two thousand 18 for is haunted Yardi,
doesn't Bisbee,
and he goes,
that looks like a Patrick Mcgee.
He's done work for my brother.
I.
Wow,
if you called
that and Joe Rogan,
you fucking amazing.
He nailed it.
I think I had to correct myself.
I said it's a one and a half times
larger.
I don't think that's right.
I think it's more like 40 percent larger
or something.
Now that I think about it,
I think I'm confusing it with something
else,
but the the copy that he makes is
definitely larger so he could work on
the finer details.
There's like blood on the teeth and the
hairs.
It's all yak hair around the head and
it's all synthetic shit in the back,
but that's,
that's his work.
But if you look at like the blood around
the teeth do.
Here's the thing,
man.
Fucking amazing.
I get great pleasure every time I come
to work and I look at that Werewolf.
I fucking love it.
I love it.
I love looking at that thing.
I love the fact that I'm a fucking grown
up
be used for anymore.
I smile all the time.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well you were showing us some shit and
you just smiled like,
wow,
that's so fucking rare smile.
You used to be a lot angrier.
I like it.
I got out of that.
You know what it's like we were talking
about before.
It's like,
what do you use in your energy on?
Are you using your energy on being upset
at things and being in this constant
sort of like a momentum of being upset
from the past that you never stop or do
you figure out a way to like hit the
brakes?
I go,
okay,
why are we angry?
What are we getting upset?
Why don't we just take all that cave man
Shit and just go smash some punching bag
and then come back to reality and be
like really relaxed about it,
but do it purposely like have some sort
of intent behind it to eliminate the
demons and I figured out how to do that.
Somewhere along the line.
Aging helps a lot,
but it's not
just that it's not aging as far as like
decay,
it's aging as far as information.
Right?
Like I was talking about like if you
were.
If people figure out a way to make
humans live to be like 900 years old,
would it be fucked up if you had sex
with 50 year old people like you fucking
asshole.
She doesn't even know any better.
It's only 50.
She's basically a baby.
Did you treat him like that until
they're 50 and say you're not an adult.
I know.
You're 12.
You can have a baby right now.
Nature has said you are ready to
actually procreate,
but we've legislated that you can't be
an adult until you're 18,
so for the next six years we're just
going to treat you like a baby.
That's an unnecessary burden for the boy
and the girl and the lack of
you're,
you're telling them every feeling that
you have naturally is wrong.
We're not going to explain that to you,
right?
Because we want to give you a good
childhood.
You shouldn't have to deal with all
these adult.
Well,
that's what their body's telling them,
so you better be honest or all of a
sudden your kids fucking a 38 year old
producer.
Well,
it's also
problem with like looking at children as
being different than a person and it's
like,
no,
this is mine.
I made them.
You are not going to like boys Michael,
you,
you're going
to like girls because you're a boy and
you're going to carry on the Harris'
name.
Okay.
I'm would,
I would have a kid just for the longterm
practical joke of raising him gay,
lesbian,
Youtube and say I was just trying to.
Who just had a kid and know he's trying
to pitch them this.
Brendan,
Brendan Walsh like,
just go and just act like you're raising
your kid gay and you know when you get
older to men,
meet each other and just say this to a
baby.
I think you could easily in this is
gonna sound fucked up.
I think you can easily convince a young
kid that like,
sex with males is normal if everyone's
doing it.
No,
no.
The idea was you have to still sex shame
the kid.
It's only okay to be gay once you're
married,
after you're 18,
but you're gay,
so these are doing.
You're married to a girl or a guy.
The end game is the kid has to
eventually,
when he's 18,
come out as straight to his parents and
that's a problem.
If you have really progressive parents
are like,
dude,
we got Super Street creds for you being
gay.
You piece of shit.
Do you think you can be straight but
trends you think you're willing to go
there?
They'll sit down at the table of
Progressive Brownie points.
We were really happy about you being
gay,
Michael and you being straight is
frankly,
it's a big bummer to our social system.
It's like they're going to think,
here's what we're going to work at the
law firm,
they're gonna think we shamed you out of
being gay and that's simply not the
case.
We have.
It's so easy gel where we can sit here
with white privilege.
Yeah,
we have.
We're not like Sam Cedar Comedy
Privilege,
which we have in droves,
which is way more way better diamond
elite status than just white privilege.
We have comedy privilege.
It's true.
They're just kidding.
No,
we're not,
but it says comic.
Okay.
If you're going to get comfy about it.
I was just kidding.
And then it's all golden.
Well,
years clearly kidding,
because you're not saying it's
specifically in a form where they trying
to disseminate information.
He try to be funny as well.
So you'll say extreme things that don't
necessarily represent your actual
viewpoint just because you want it to be
more hilarious.
If Sam Cedar were funny all the time,
rather than that one tweet who'd be
fine.
Sorry Sam.
Brightmore.
Jesus.
It's true.
But we have the luxury of having a
social circle that is very tolerant to
the n word degree tolerant in a green.
Wait a minute.
You can't say nigger word degree.
Oh,
that was yesterday.
I.
It doesn't even make sense.
It sounds like a gratuitous use of the
N.
No,
I was saying that in a green room when
it's just comics nigger,
retard con,
diked fucking everything flies.
Yes,
and when it doesn't,
you get super upset.
Like if someone says,
ah,
she's a con,
and someone goes,
hey man,
really shouldn't feel upset.
What you say,
you're a cunt to a feminist comedian in
the confines of a Green Room.
Everyone's free and clear.
It leaves the green rooms.
I've been part of.
Nobody has a problem with Yukon.
Amanda Monacan?
Nope.
Not In the UK,
but I mean even in America if you will,
that the guy I've really as a con,
right?
Like,
sorry,
you looked immediately San again when
you said that.
I'm just,
he's looking at me,
he's not a and I'm just trying to bring
them into the conversation.
Like if you're,
you mean pull him out of his fucking
laptop a little bit,
but you know,
owns.
We're all talking.
We're friends.
Like Saddam Hussein was a cunt.
His kid would cons his kids.
I heard there were cuts those sons.
Nobody cares.
You could say that the two.
I don't know.
He might've had other sons.
I don't know if they're kind of shift.
There were two cousins who was one of
them,
cuts.
They apparently like would find people
where they were getting married.
They would take the broad raper and then
they would feed her two dogs.
Well that's a little calendula.
They were off the top evil over the top.
Whoa.
Yeah.
I read that and I had to stop reading.
I was like,
okay,
I can't go on with us.
That's another thing about aging,
not giving a fuck,
but also giving more of a fuck.
We were kids were the same age.
We would watch all that faces a death.
Couldn't get enough of it.
Now I don't want to.
No,
no,
I can't watch that shit.
Did you try that Steve?
You know,
of course.
Looking at it,
I'm like,
he cracked that.
He's never going to drink it.
Never going to drink it.
So good.
It makes my dick hard.
Thing goes all sugar free and she,
she,
she used to like get a diet coke.
We're going through a drive through diet
coke and they pressed the little thing
on the top of the to show you which
one's diet,
which ones?
Regular check this to make sure because
she knows how much I hate artificial
sweeteners.
Tea,
I don't want to know because I don't
drink that for the aftertaste.
Never leaves your fucking mouth.
Stevie is no different.
Splenda,
what's the sucralose?
It's awful.
If you just try this for me.
If you're thirsty,
diabetic and you pull up to the Wendy's
drive through at 1:45
AM,
what percentage of the time do you get a
giant Vat of sugar?
If you like extra large diet coke.
That's it.
Okay.
Don't at least one out of 100.
You're getting Nevada sugar water,
right?
At least 100 mean.
I'm assuming.
It's kind of like in restaurants.
They don't bring anything other than
DECAF.
After 8:00,
I think the dude who's monitoring that
thing is gonna slip on a of his own
drool and slammed his head into the
regular coke and it's gonna.
Fill your shit up,
but something that's going to give you a
seizure.
That's what I think.
I'm going to fill that fucking thing up
to the top.
Very little eyes.
Oh,
this is where I was going.
I fucking had a thing I was going to.
Oh,
this is about Hennigan.
Yeah.
Last year,
a year ago.
A little bit over a year ago.
End of the world podcast.
Oh know.
I don't know if I've seen you once since
then.
I think we saw each other once you came
to the store once you'd been back on
here.
I think,
I don't know,
maybe maybe the end of the world
podcast.
I was not in a good place to say least,
but I will tell you one thing that I
said to all my friends,
I said,
I admire the fact that you push through
it and even though you were like a
little bit like flustered,
you were still gregarious.
I can't watch the video.
I'm sure you were in a weird place.
We tell everybody why,
and my Gal Bingo had just gone into a
possibly terminal.
She had a seizure,
fell down,
smashed her head on the cement,
life-flighted in a coma.
She might not make it.
If she does make it,
it might be worst than not making it at
all.
And I said,
uh,
I didn't know how to handle that.
Fuck,
I didn't know either,
but I made the decision since it
happened during her 40th birthday party.
So all of our friends and family were at
the house in [inaudible].
It happens.
So she's surrounded by all these people
who took a week off to be there for a
five day party.
They're there.
I can't help her.
She's in a coma.
Me Standing with the family,
staring at a half corpse is not going to
help bucket.
I'm going to do this thing.
This is a big deal.
And it was a huge.
Them epic Douglas.
Fucking amazing.
We were there when Doug,
Donald Trump was elected president and
bill burr might've had the greatest
podcast appearance of all time.
It was like,
it was like one of them,
Michael Jordan,
things that you would walk your kid and
you're like,
what the fuck?
It's how he,
his whole heckler youtube thing in
Philly.
That's him.
And now he one upped it by doing the end
of the world podcast fire.
It was on fire.
I mean,
he was on fire with a point where
everybody's stepped back,
except who was the gal that had a
different Sarah?
I don't know if it was all because of
Brian Hennigan.
Exactly.
So this is where we're going because I
wanted to name drop Olivia grace.
She's hilarious.
Fucking funny.
She was like 17.
Yeah,
she's,
she said she started once.
She's 18 now she's 22.
She just did a show up my house.
They were just on tour that lend a.
God dammit.
I can't remember something Jewish.
Uh,
with the first name June with juicing.
Oh No,
they're on tour.
Fuck,
I'm sorry.
Julie Guy.
Julie.
Uh,
they were both funny.
They showed up.
Julie
goddamned look it up,
find it somehow.
Olivia grace's twitter,
she's on tour.
Olivia grades.
So they come through,
they had a night off and they stayed at
the house and we forced them to do a
show.
Oh,
it's sounds like great.
I don't know if that was Thanksgiving or
what.
You forced them to do a show.
Yeah.
Well she's going to have to watch me
jerk off in 20 years doing a show.
Forcing someone to do a show is going to
be the new rate.
Eric Friedman,
Julie,
the first names.
Not True.
Anyway,
they went up,
so you have original soul rock Kenny go
up and do rapid burst,
so we'll have a little stage in our
little fun house where we do our podcast
that we.
We can make it a show like that and it's
always the best audiences.
Never as a shell failed there.
They're always great because my house
yet,
but my.
The people that come to my house,
don't.
They couldn't name their favorite
comedian because they don't know.
They'd go,
Whoa,
Jim Belushi,
Zio comedian.
Still they don't.
They're great.
They killed.
She fucking crushed.
Cool.
What she told me,
let's get back to the end of the world
podcast.
I had told Hennigan,
yeah,
we should probably have some kind of
diversity.
This is before that night deal.
Well,
now when we were planning it out,
what it should be that night,
I'm fucked my head.
Is My lady going to live or die?
Why am I here?
I shouldn't have done this.
Let's make the best of it.
I go in the bathroom and the shower some
for some reason they have a shower,
the back of the comedy store and the
Green.
So stupid.
I would go back there and I'd fucking
fall apart crying and then I come back
out on stage and try to keep it
together.
Well,
Hennigan is still thinking.
I told what we need women on this.
It's all white men,
so he's just.
He has no discretion.
He's just getting any woman and forcing
her onstage and you're going,
what the fuck?
Why isn't I know that I was.
No,
no.
You didn't know.
You were saying why she.
I go,
I,
it's probably my fault.
I probably.
Why your manager saying we need women.
While that's probably.
I probably said it,
but uh,
here's the thing that's important.
Most of the people that you had on that
day is that,
that stage,
whether it's bill burr or whether it's
Bert Kreischer or doug or me.
Jeffrey showed up at his kid.
That was the weirdest thing was that was
weird.
He came on stage with a little kid and
we were like,
hey man,
you can't.
You literally can't do this legally,
like legally can't do this.
I can't say it's okay to do this.
We can't talk about the same things that
we were going to talk in front of your
kick and create.
Like if you have your kid on stage and
Doug wants to talk about anal vibrators
and like it's the hardest he's ever come
and the,
the,
the Gal was drowning and gagging,
but it felt so good.
He's like,
how long does it take before
you can resuscitate someone with no
brain damage?
Like what if she blacks out from all the
comments coming out because there's this
vibrator back in front of his kid.
I don't want to.
Let me get the point and let's go back
to this please,
because Olivia grace,
when she was down in Brisbane,
she said she was there that night when
Brian Hennigan was scouring the audience
for female comics.
She's lost.
She's very boyish.
She has a very short haircut.
She's very boyish and he say,
no,
we need female comedians,
comedians,
and he,
he tapped her and he went,
not,
you moved on.
You're a piece of shit.
Olivia,
if I did that,
a discredited.
If there's a better story,
should have brought her out.
You're fired anyway.
From the production of the end of the
world part two.
Um,
let's do another one when you want to do
it.
We have to find.
I've been looking for it since you said
that.
Let's do in January was due at the
comedy store in January and let's just
find some random Tuesday.
It bitch.
Shut the fuck up.
Who let this guy talk?
It'd be good if you had somebody to
swimming or some blacks.
Do you have any people of color?
We can visit the podcast,
which.
Oh listen,
you're not adopted to America.
You're influencing art.
How dare you?
That's due to the nursery of the dod.
Perhaps we should make this podcast
comprised with.
Sure.
You just want to be in Islamophobia.
It's gonna be on Youtube.
Don't want to ruin the desert.
New ideas in the middle of the desert.
We need equal parts,
vaginas and credences.
Doesn't matter if one of you are.
Come on.
We got to avoid criticism at all costs.
Last
I again,
I take credit.
I was probably the one who said it.
No.
Say it's my fault.
I fucked up.
I shouldn't talk to everybody
beforehand.
There was no option to talk to the
security guards and said don't let
anybody back here and no one gets on
stage unless doug and I say yes.
Tell Hannigan shut the fuck up.
I know.
Only from hearing secondhand.
Even though I was there,
I knew there was whatever that girl was.
There was a Santana.
Morgan Murphy was already.
He's amazing.
He doesn't look down on like Sarah Tiana
too.
I wasn't there when the issue happened,
but she apparently had some issue and it
was,
it was a non.
It was done.
It was all not a humorous discussion.
It was like a sincere know how bad it
was that Donald Trump was going to win
and how bad it was for women because it
was right after the grab them by the
Pussy video or audio.
So there was a lot of shit going on,
you know,
I wasn't there.
I'd gone to the other room.
I did a set in the or and I came back
and everybody's like,
Oh man,
you missed his crazy blowout.
But she and Bill Burr and Sarah Tiana.
That's my point is that is not a
negative or a deficit.
If there's huge blown up conflict and
the broadcast people.
Actually that's not what we planned.
You're right.
People will click on it because they
heard at some point there is a big blow
out as long as we can keep Sarah Tiana
off twitter for a couple of weeks.
I definitely don't know or I don't want
this to her,
but I mean reading the people that had
commented on it,
like some of the people were like
particularly fucking mean when they
commented on it.
I'm like,
okay,
okay.
Everybody relax.
Bingo.
Put out a book.
It's not a book.
It's a.
She won her first mental institution
stay when she was 50 1:50
against her will when she was hardcore.
Crazy before we get together.
She wrote like a Anne Frank Diary in the
moment of what's going on and she put
that out as a book or Anne Frank's diary
and you know,
Bingo.
She's a soft touch and you can't read
comments.
Oh yeah,
you're not strong enough people on the
Internet.
This is going to be someone who's a
fucking ass hole,
so just don't go there.
She does.
Eventually someone's going to be a
fucking cock sucker and you're not going
to be able to handle it.
You're not like us.
I have a hard to.
I won't look at fucking youtube
comments.
I don't want to know.
You know?
Well,
it's just not.
Here's the thing.
I wish everybody was cool and there's a.
there's an absolute reality when you do,
you put out as much content as you or I
or a lot of us is going to be some stuff
that you like and stuff that you don't
like and it's just going to be styles
you like.
There's certain people that don't like
someone.
Someone in the other day online.
I showed a picture of me and Dave attell
and they're like,
fuck that guy.
He's never funny.
I'm like,
Oh my God,
you can exist.
I'm not.
I don't think you should die,
but I can't talk to you.
I just can't.
I just don't.
I don't know.
I just,
I got done watching David Tell for 20
minutes the Improv with a half a crowd
and I was fucking literally crying it me
to do comedy again.
It was wonderful.
It was a break.
I got to be an audience member.
It was amazing with somebody out there.
It was like,
fuck that guy.
Does he?
What did he say?
Fuck.
That guy was sitting next to me in that
room that night,
man.
There's no way.
There was only like that might've been
60 people in that room and tell was
destroying.
I mean destroying.
I was like,
you can't say fuck that guy.
If you watch that.
It was so funny.
I.
It isn't often the case.
I handled the steps
with Doug's audience.
Do you hate headphones that are hurting
my fucking ears?
She gets can swap out fucking sweat.
Is it the case that there's somebody
who's like,
one of Doug's fans who's like,
I'm helping Joe by saying get rid of
that guy because I just want to hear a
few gaps.
The problem with the last comic standing
is people go,
oh,
you're a way better than so and so.
It's not a competition,
and should they do that in your face?
But they'll do it to you.
They'll walk right up to you and go so
much funnier than that guy.
The guy that you brought out of your own
pocket because you thought that this guy
should be known to your audience.
They act like this opening act was
forced upon,
you know,
I brought him out of my own pocket
because I thought you would enjoy him
and he needs to be seen and you're
fucking.
I like that you do that.
You do that.
Like I do that.
I think that's super important.
You know,
bring guys like Brendan Walsh out on the
road and all these dudes you bring out
and tell people about them.
But that's a,
that's a big part about this era as
opposed to the old arrows is that I
think this era is more supportive.
There's more opportunities so people
don't feel famine,
you know,
don't feel like,
oh,
we one guard can be the host of the
tonight show.
But that's not a thing anymore.
Like if somebody offered me the tonight
show,
I'd be like,
what do you want me to do?
You want me to go and fucking talk about
shit I don't want to talk about for like
how,
what do you think happens if you make
more money?
We didn't have Ferguson last night.
Ferguson,
where the line is a segment where the
riots took place.
No,
no.
Craig Ferguson.
We did his podcast last night and I told
him,
I go,
I hated you when I first saw you because
I don't watch late night.
But if I was flipping channels and I saw
you for a minute with your accent and
getting your face into that like Fisheye
lens thing he would do in his monologue.
I didn't like you until I heard you on
stern and I all of a sudden he was a
human being for an hour and 20 minutes.
He's a guy with good stories and he
hated.
He is like no one would accept the fact
that he did not want to do anything
else.
They're offering them other projects.
He's like,
no,
I'm,
I'm good.
I'm done.
Well,
you know,
holly,
we quit.
Quit.
I mean nothing.
That's the greatest thing about his
decision making.
Like he's like,
I don't want to do this anymore.
Now he does stand up and he just did a
Netflix special and he's doing a podcast
because he goes,
I got to do something.
I didn't want to talk,
but I don't want to do it by their rules
and no one believes when you don't have
that Kinda half the through line of the
book is when you,
I want to do what I do,
but no one buys that.
You don't need to be more famous.
I don't.
I,
uh,
I did to plant little of eggplant and I
don't like it.
I know I don't want more
excellence.
Delicious.
With stevie on it,
fucking eggplant Parmesan.
One time my mother tried to make it and
it was so grotesque that when she's
saying you got to eat it,
and then when she tried it,
she goes,
all right,
I'll give.
Give me all your plates.
This came out bad.
Sorry.
Well maybe that's what it was.
Maybe if you went to Trenton yonkers or
something like that.
If you don't like a little bit of fame,
you know you're not going to like a lot.
So it's not like.
Well yeah,
I think you like a little bit.
Let's be a little bit and I think a
little bit is good.
I think it's all good as long as the
numbers and manageable and you can stay
yourself.
I think the real problems when you go.
Look,
here's the best example,
Michael Jackson who has never been a
better example in the world of toxicity
due to celebrity status.
Like you hit critical levels.
You hit some three mile island shit.
You hit some Chernobyl shit.
It's impossible to maintain the amount
of energy that's coming your way as a
normal human being.
I mean,
you don't have any unique DNA that
allows you to deal with the idea that
300 million people know who you are or
more Jackson Swath of your clothing Dna
out and put it in a petri dish and make
a fucking cloning it and frame it and
put it in their man cave and there's a
bunch of people to think that maybe
you're molesting kids and you've got to
fucking amusement park in the backyard
and you're literally losing your mind
and you tell a guy,
hey man,
I can't sleep.
I want you to analysts anesthetize me
every night in a fucking tube.
Just put,
put me in some fucking crazy hyperbaric
chamber and pumping the gas.
I mean,
this guy was off the fucking
reservation.
There had never been anybody that famous
before.
He was literally the guy with the candle
at the end of the universe going,
oh my God,
I think there's.
Keep.
See there's more room.
There's no one's ever been here before.
No one's ever been that famous.
What happened?
He went crazy.
He went completely insane and died young
and no,
and nowhere between 1990 and 2017.
Does it look like any of what's happened
to him is manageable?
It's like he's running down a hill,
like tumbling down a hill and he's okay
for the first decade.
Maybe the first two decades.
After awhile he's just getting chewed
the fuck up psychologically.
Physically he keeps getting more plastic
surgery.
I don't think he was ever very stable.
Psychologic.
Oh No,
I don't think so either.
I mean,
I don't know,
but if you ever seen that document
around them,
it's fucking love.
That documentary is the first time.
This is it.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
Earlier again,
I don't know.
Music to watch that you go,
oh,
this guy really didn't know what the
fuck you was doing.
I just don't get it.
He was really brilliant.
I just think the songs suck.
Well they suck,
but in terms of like what you want to
hear right now,
look,
everything requires context.
Right?
Like if you were.
Do you remember when I was a kid,
and I remember this really clearly
because I was in high school and I was
living at home and I was listening to
Debbie,
a C O Z in Boston?
No.
W fnx.
No,
no way.
Jose.
That was right.
WC O Z and Boston.
It was a radio station in Boston in 19
eighties is rock and roll station and
the guy came on who was a DJ.
I wish I could remember.
It wasn't mark Parenteau who's like the
big ones in the morning,
but the guy came on.
He played Michael Jackson.
He played a Michael Jackson Song.
Yeah,
I think it was beat it and he said,
look,
I know this.
No,
he played Billie Jean.
He goes,
I know this isn't rock and roll because
it's so good.
I have to play.
And he played it and he played billy
Jean and I remember it was no twitter
back their book and with this anchor
music.
Well not only that,
this guy was a real dj.
He was like one of the last of the real
djs.
They could literally decide,
hey,
I just heard this man Jack Umay.
Yeah,
this Lou Reed record that you fuckers
have to hear from the beginning to the
end.
I want you to listen from the beginning
to the end,
so I'm going to play this.
You know,
you hear Bruce springsteen when he was
like 30,
you know,
like beginning to the end,
those days should do that.
He used to sit there and listen and
you'd be he that doesn't exist anymore
like that and there's too many.
This is one of the problems with money,
right?
There's problems with trademarks and the
ability to put things on youtube and
whether or not you can get credit for
this or put that up,
but that up like a radio station if just
wanting to appear right now and pr and
do like that kind of a thing.
It probably be almost impossible.
Like how many radio stations are there
in the world where they would let you
just play a whole brief bruce
springsteen album from the beginning to
the end.
Terrestrial radio at this point
probably play child porn.
Just soundtracks and no one's listening
anymore.
Do you still do like no uber in the
morning when you have to promote a Gig?
I don't have.
I don't,
but I miss some people.
I Miss Kevin and being johnny dare in
Kansas City.
Ms Dot that guy.
He's like,
you didn't have to do it,
but Johnny Darren,
I have enough of the history.
So when I went to Kansas City,
I got there the night before.
I said,
all right,
if I wake up at 6:00
AM,
which I did,
and we went down just for fun and we
took over morning radio and Johnny dare
in passing.
He's like,
he knows my house is all weird.
So he's showing me pictures of his house
and he's got all sorts of fucked up
weird kind of things.
And
what's his name?
Patrick Mcgee.
Oh,
like,
no.
I go,
uh,
my,
my tour manager Greg Jaylee does ghost
ride.
He goes to all this shit came from ghost
I go to the St Louis.
Yeah.
That's the second time now that a
morning radio guy like Joe Rogan morning
ready me,
my hennessy's over their breeding
Hennessy.
Well,
no,
actually I was just checking up on it.
I was just reading the comments and
seeing if we should also start against
bringing more diversity.
I've got a few African students who
would like to have in the studio for the
record.
Hennigan is not technically a guest.
His name is Hennessy,
but when,
when Hennessy's wearing a guest on my
podcast,
he does the same thing.
He'll sit there and fucking read your
laptop while you're a guest.
You can't do that shit,
bitch.
I just wanted to look at these.
He was fine.
He was tweeting.
Was looking at the uh,
because I remember noticing this before
somebody edited out the best of Bill
Burr on the podcast election night as a
standalone video.
Yeah.
It's got 900,000
views.
Just the best of bilberry smashed it.
He smashed it.
It was so perfect for him because he had
got his fucking held it up.
It was awesome,
but it was great to have all will keep
coming in.
Do you have a great lesson?
You got it.
You and I have been friends for so long.
I knew what you were going through.
I was like,
I just don't know what to do.
I didn't know how to handle it.
I didn't know to joke around with.
I was trying to bail a lot of it.
Before the coma.
I was saying,
I don't.
I don't think I'm the guy for the job.
You're like,
fuck you,
you're coming to la.
So then when the seizure happened,
I go,
he's to think that her coma is an
excuse,
but I've always been a about Marilyn
Manson backstage with a golf shirt on or
something.
Oh my God.
He showed up.
He showed up like the end of the movie
flight,
which is the best ending to a movie
ever.
That's the Denzel Washington where he
crashes the plane,
but he saves the entire crew like holly.
Right?
Last,
but he was fine.
He was jacked and fucked in the movie
and at the end he's drunk as shit and
John Goodman,
his drug dealer comes in and fixes them
with cocaine so he can testify it's the
best ending of a movie or that movie.
Watch the beginning and then fast
forward through the fluff in the middle
and get to the end and it's one of the
best Madsen showed up where there's amy
takedowns beginning.
They said our toad artois art.
There's a giant picture in Johnny's
house where I'm staring at this.
It looks like Manson and I fuck Manson.
As weird and unstable as he is is the
only guy I can think of that would
understand where I am right now,
why I'm here,
how fucked I am,
what's going on,
and I called him and he answered his
phone,
which he never answers his phone at 5:30
at night,
which is morning for him and I told him
what's going on.
He said,
I'll be there in 30 minutes,
and he showed up with Krispy kremes and
cocaine and each problem,
and then he showed up and he sat
backstage.
He wouldn't come out onstage and once
were I was beckoning for to come out.
That's when his management people caught
wind of the fact that he's about to go
out and his handler had to drag him
away,
but he saved my fucking life that night.
Whereas fucking handlers,
who knows we need to talk to them that
tell them they'll be relaxed right now.
Re lacks.
Settle down.
You're,
you're handling Maryland motherfucking
Manson.
Okay.
Alright.
There you go.
It's not Jim Nabors.
Okay.
You just lose one of them guys that are
actually still doing rock and roll guy.
Really doing it.
God you.
They just want to.
What do they want to do?
Keep him out of legal trouble.
Keep them alive to get the fuck out of
here.
You need like a secondary version.
You need to like,
like guys who are lawyers who were on
adderall and they report to the lawyers
who are sober or give like two filters.
You know,
dudes like understand people on coke
because they're basically on like some
sort of synthetic coke and then you have
a report like they have.
There were like police body cameras and
they report to the lawyers who are sober
get drug tested every day.
I'm like okay,
what exactly was going on?
And everybody be like,
everybody has a say and they,
they been count together and they go,
what?
How do we,
how do we handle this?
Well,
we handle this by the fact that we're
handling,
man,
I'm fucking Manson.
Let them do it.
Let them go.
Give him the gun.
Gave him the rubber gloves by the
rubber.
He's such a sweet dude.
Yeah,
he's a very nice guy.
I met him a couple of times.
He's always been very friendly,
like genuinely friendly.
Sorry I turned that on.
I've got to show you a picture.
I can't wait to tweet this right.
That you shut off your phone like a
gentleman.
Plus,
I like the fact that your phone makes us
starting noise from 2006.
What is that?
One of them sound and Samson used to
bust my balls because I was the last guy
with a flip phone.
So depressing and you'd have all the new
gadgetry and I was so proud to have a
flip phone,
but when we started working in the UK,
nobody calls everyone only texts because
I guess phone calls,
cost of fucking thousand pounds a minute
or something.
So I had to actually get a smart phone,
but I still long for the flip phone days
will samsung just came out with a new
phone that's a hybrid.
It's a combination of a smartphone and a
flip phone and you open it up and you
can get an actual keyboard and he talked
to people just like a regular flip phone
and when you're done you hang it up and
the front of the phone is a Bezel.
Lists smartphone.
So the front of the phone?
Yeah.
Like you could do text messages,
you can view the Internet and then when
you want to open it up and make phone
calls that acts like a regular old
school flip phone and people really like
it.
In terms of like pressing physical
buttons.
Yes.
Yeah.
Have you seen you watch a movie on your
fucking smart phone?
I know people that have a busy,
they don't have cable.
That's why football is popular at my
house because no one has
tv so they can't watch it unless they
come to my house.
But I know people that watch,
they'll just sit and watch an entire
movie on a phone.
Right?
I can't watch it on a 32 inch screen.
I.
I need a big fucking screen and watch a
movie.
Yeah.
I think 100 percent.
And I go.
The only time that there's that phone,
the only time is when you're on a plane
or something,
you're trapped and all you have is your
phone.
Look at that phone doug.
Look at that screen.
So the front of it is 60 inches.
That will be an awkward phone call.
You can't carry that around Bro.
You don't even understand inches,
bro.
That's a the size of like an iphone six
or some shit.
Actually it was a little bigger than
that.
Doesn't jammies with how big is it?
Is a big screen.
I had it on another page.
This is when I had to decide which
picture goes in the book in which
doesn't cause there's too many dick
pics.
I deleted this and put in the me pulling
my dick out in front of Louis Ck.
But I can't wait to tweet this.
Let me see that.
I have to apologize.
I was wrong.
You touched it wrong.
I didn't touch you that Jesus Christ his
angry.
By the way,
this is a bad touch.
Touch Rogan.
GotTa ramp.
The thing up here.
Yeah,
we.
Are we out?
Are we going towards A.
Yeah.
I pulled my dick out in front of her,
but what about the three or four people
in between?
Everybody seems okay with it.
Yeah.
That was back when I was kind of my
thing.
Sarah Silvermans there.
She's now.
That's the ask.
Did you ask first?
No,
no.
I was vacation telling them picture I
was fluffing.
But are you prepared for shame?
I'm,
I'm ready for it.
You might get it.
You wouldn't have to get this.
Um,
is there a place where people can view
this or is it a good example?
I was going to tweet it.
Hmm.
Let me talk to you about this.
All right.
Let's wait.
I've got somebody said,
Sarah Silverman.
Well,
Sarah Silverman is a friend and a
wonderful comedian and a colleague and I
think you and I both respect her as I
do.
I don't think that's what I didn't want
her to get into any trouble because she
wrote a,
is it okay to love Louis ck thing?
Is it okay to love?
Here's me with my dick out.
Here's the thing.
It might not be anymore.
This is why we need to burn that.
You need to burn your whole phone.
You need to get modern phone that allows
you to take photos and get online and
then you need to burn that thing because
you can't.
Can't have those pictures.
You can't have those pictures floating
around.
It's important,
man.
I'm sorry.
I was the guy that put it out.
It's so sad.
Those are.
Those are developed pictures from a
photo mat.
I think it's gonna take a little time,
but once,
once we get through this we're going to
find some sort of a reasonable,
a agreement where when you can and
cannot pull your dick out because what
we needed to do when people are young
boys and girls install a small,
like a,
some sort of a sexual equivalent to a
Turkey tester or something like a,
like a green light,
you know,
like acting like goes off like,
okay,
you can pull your dick out now sir,
like I'm 23 years old,
I'd be going to college,
but that sex would pull your dick out.
It's when you're our age that's
inappropriate.
Unless they're our age two,
which you know what,
there's no 50 year old comics hitting on
50 year old women,
which is a maybe.
But like what if it's a woman like
Christie Brinkley,
she's like 63.
She's still hot as fuck.
Well then you go,
oh my God,
I'm your age so I know who you are.
Unlike young men,
you're just happy to be there.
You don't pull your dick out.
I wish I did this years ago when it was
erect.
How many people would be mad if a woman
pulled her vagina out?
Almost zero.
Right?
Like who would feel threatened?
That's the real problem.
The real problem is the physical
violence potential and the number of
people that have been raped.
That's the real problem because it was
just about weird sex.
Things like,
well,
this is an which is the bit that has
been working on is the difference
between hot as fuck.
Take it or leave it.
Come on,
bitch.
Christie Brinkley does not live a human
life in perfect lighting with perfect
makeup.
You don't need the dark ones with no.
At some point she's hunched over like I
am with this posture,
wearing reading glasses thicker than
ours.
Trying to focus on something on a laptop
and that spill bellies hanging over cunt
because eight kids came out of it.
That's when you both put on mascot masks
like you are the squirrel and she's the
raccoon and you guys just fucked by the
firelight.
Just get right in front of that God damn
fireplace and go to town,
molly and overrated because it leads to
all these problems.
Certainly can.
It certainly can lead to a like a weird
unofficial bond with people,
right?
Like if everybody.
Imagine this,
if,
if like hugging people if like
committing to hugging people was like as
intimate as community to having sex with
people.
Well hugging people is really quick and
no one says,
oh,
he hugged too soon.
He,
I was.
I was hoping it was going to be a long
hug,
but his hug was done like in seconds
like he was a teenager and his first
hug,
like the man does not have the right to
pull out of the hug before the woman
wants to end the hug like the period.
We all know this.
Can you hug twice in a night?
No,
no,
don't do it.
Because the second hug will be
unenthusiastic and not representative of
your soul who you are as a spiritual
being.
You need to only hug fucking once a
week.
Once asked someone you love.
Porn has changed the game.
Porn has ruined fucking and it's
continuing to ruin.
Fucking like that.
It's just setting you up for robot.
Fuck dolls.
Have you seen that stripper?
A robot that gyrates on the.
On the,
uh,
the pole.
There's a robot that goes on the
stripper pole and it's clearly a robot.
You see all the mechanical parts,
but it's moving his ass like some
beautiful woman with a perfect ass.
You okay?
Okay.
Like we are so close to not being able
to tell.
Like I don't know if we understand what
exponential increases in technology are.
Look at this.
Lead this robot.
She's gyrating on this poll.
So she's holding this pole.
Okay.
Well right now you could see your joints
and all that stuff and I know she's done
a human even though she's wearing high
heeled shoes.
How many more years do we have before
that is fixed,
but how,
how,
how often did you need that?
You went to see strippers because you
wanted the threat of getting pussy.
You didn't need her to spin around a
brass pole.
If she was just there vacant,
robotic and ask a sleigh and Akimbo you
just fuck her,
you wouldn't go,
I need you to dance.
I need to want it more.
All that does is make you want it when
you didn't want it to begin with.
Oh,
I didn't think about fucking till she
did all that thing on the brass poll.
Now I have a boner,
now I'm using that as my leader.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Not particularly thinking about fucking
Brian.
And then there's a girl dancing around a
brass pole.
Cidex shaking her ass.
So now I have a boner.
Now I'm thinking about fucking where I
would've just talked to you.
Well,
for girls just sitting outside,
reading a book,
not thinking about fucking and Jason
Momoa shows up and he's in an open
shirt,
like some sort of cis guy that you
fantasize about.
Game of thrones,
put them on and his.
He's chopping wood.
Travis with his name.
Travis.
Jamie.
Jamie's tropic chopping wood with a
giant ax and the girls get all juicy.
Just looking at him because he's
perfect.
That's him.
Shut the fuck.
Come on.
I was going to say with a nipple ring,
but that was the cursor.
Come on.
It's a handsome man and he's a very
friendly too.
I met him at whole foods.
You're not,
as you say,
he's not because you're not a woman,
by the way.
It's about six visits.
Baseball player.
What's his name from the nationals?
The most beautiful men in sports.
I was called Jason.
Uh,
Joe,
just the guy with the big beard from the
nationals.
He's fucking biking,
but that guy's a muscle bound.
You're in a weird dudes.
I'm going to have to.
Is the girls like worth worth with an e,
W,
e r t h?
That guy is fucking gorgeous.
It's not a competition is.
It?
Is.
It is what I want to have an issue with
Jason Momoa.
We're gonna end this podcast with a
twitter.
A bit like invite ladies because we both
have 80 percent male fan basis.
More than that.
I went and I went on instagram.
It looks Jason Worth.
Okay.
I'm with you.
That's the one.
The one you just touch and that's the
one was traps.
Fucking that guy.
I've been able to get naked photos of
base ball bat a giant one,
not even one of those ways.
We give out for free for ladies
listening.
Jason Werth or Jason Momoa.
Oh,
I'll battle of the Jason.
Jason's.
Listen,
it's just a matter of like,
what do you want to do?
Do?
Do you want to live in a margin or do
you want to live on the beach and raise
your kids in the sand?
Okay.
You gotTa pick your poison.
I have no idea how he came over on the
fucking raft.
Like he's some kind of Polynesian.
God.
He's from Hawaii.
It's like six foot of the most expensive
state to live in.
Only for one refuge for white people.
You're not even paying attention to.
You want me to.
Islands are on Hawaii pro,
so racist five.
Sorry.
Is this a bonus question?
Do you smell like smoke enough that
you're going to get in trouble when you
get home?
How old are your kids now?
Seven and nine for the young ones I
forgot.
Uh,
uh,
daddy smells like cigarette smoke.
I've got shirts here that I could
change,
but it's good that you did this,
you chain smoke through this because we
realized this system sucks.
Yeah,
I noticed that.
Or whatever is making the system.
I've been breathing it.
I definitely got a secondhand nicotine
high.
It should be cold to in the air.
Just good.
We'll get a call.
Jason Dill.
Tell me before you showed them,
hey,
you got to think like a bar,
a bar.
Don't think like your grandma smoked in
occasionally in the bathroom.
He said,
I said,
did Rogan put this system in
specifically for me?
And he goes,
I think so.
Definitely for you and dice clay you
tell to tell.
Yeah,
he's another one.
I can't live without.
The cigarettes were outside and just
keeps going.
He's just had five days off of them
coming into this.
Did you really for five day quit
everything for five days except
medicinal drinking.
Do a couple shots of whiskey because at
this point can't quit cold Turkey.
Very dangerous.
Broadly understand.
So now when you,
uh,
what was harder,
um,
what does it feel like to take five days
off of cigarettes?
When I do it my way,
perfect.
Fantastic.
Because I.
No one can come around me if I don't
have to do a phoner or write a thing.
Write a book.
When you write to you like to.
Well that's the hardest thing of
everything I just go to doing stand up
writing is.
That's where it's integral to the
process chain.
Smoking,
tap,
smoke,
whiskey,
drank.
Tap,
tap,
tap.
Yeah.
Everything else I get over writing was
the only.
You don't want to find like sometimes
some of my best bits have been me drunk
on an airplane.
I have the exact opposite where I talk
about I get off an airplane drunk and I
have stacks of cocktail napkins.
I say if it says Delta on the Napkin,
this job sucks and they're not even
jokes there pontificating.
What about this and that?
Twice in 20 years
I've gotten good bits off of drunk
airplane
twice in 20 years.
A good number though.
If you could find one thing where you
could do like 300 times,
you get 20 great bits or twice to grow.
Even to like,
like think about how many days you spent
trying to write to get two great bits.
It's the amount of bad bits though where
yeah,
I'm embarrassed to have the Napkin in my
pocket.
Like,
what the fuck does this even have those
saved on.
Smith has a great show.
He's doing where he has you pulled out
your old notebook.
Fucking cock sucker.
Told me
Brian Hannigan.
You Lazy Bitch.
No.
Doing it for awhile.
First Notebook where you have to go and
read the shit you wrote in 1990 that you
thought was brilliant.
Yes.
Well,
here's the thing.
We're trying to send a tweet about it.
Why does it have to be I shall 20
individual and how come you kind of do
it just.
Well,
see how he just shut the fuck up because
he knows he's wrong.
Oh No,
actually joe just made my point.
You weren't listening to anything.
Is anything wrong with you going over
your your notebook,
but going into other people's notebooks
then you're sort of like,
if you decide like,
hey,
I'm doug stanhope,
I want to break out my notebook and tell
you how fucking terrible my $19 goes
into other people's notebooks.
No,
Owen Smith,
not Owen.
Benjamin,
Benjamin's upstate New York.
Owen Smith,
la.
Hilarious comedian.
He goes into yours.
I had to bring out my shit.
I brought out some shit from 1990.
I had some like 1991 notebooks.
There were terrible.
I had like orchestrated crowd work and
then you ask the crowd boos.
Knew a girl.
Oh,
it was brutal.
It was sold.
Oh,
I want to be on that show.
Created it,
but by creator didn't create feed into
flowers.
Oh,
and Smith.
Good on you for doing it first.
How long ago did you guys come up with
the idea when everyone else was coming
up with other.
I did it about a year ago.
A list in the last three years.
Yeah.
I did his thing within a year and he
already had it
filming it.
I am not.
Hey,
comedy and policies that are civilians
listening.
Don't do.
I'm not saying he stole my idea.
I don't know.
It's the WHO.
It's the nurse that think they are the
comedy police.
Don't talk to Tommy's.
Just let them be dummies.
Hate it.
Hey,
I saw so and so did your bit.
He was talking about porn and you talk
about porn.
You fucking shut up.
Let us police ourselves registered to be
in Manhattan to patch the tires.
Oh,
today I'm going.
So Irish,
which is better because he hates the
Irish.
I was about to.
I was about to closing this podcast
because I'm saving a piss either.
I'm going to Piss.
Let it go and let it slide that book
over here.
And also Brian has notes.
First of all,
what's important is a hey,
diversity.
We'd like to have more diversity in this
room,
but diversity,
diversity,
diversity is what were the tour?
We say more women podcast or.
Go ahead.
So the tour,
uh,
Doug Stan Hope Australia.
April 2018 down under.
But the world is flat.
It's not me heckling myself.
Doug Stanhope Australia in April.
He's going to be an Adelaide,
Brisbane,
Canberra,
Melbourne,
Perth,
Sydney Park.
So we don't be.
Oh,
don't you don't me will come to the end
of the rainbow.
So Irish in him and it makes them even
snappier.
Oh,
before that we're also doing a Hong Kong
Singapore system.
Be Racist.
I can't have this on my podcast.
Who?
Ci Men.
God,
he's still a guy.
He's still over there.
Yeah,
I think he does karaoke or something.
I don't know.
So Doug Stan hope.com.
Just go there.
Buy The book.
Here's the book,
Ladies and Gentlemen,
I really need.
The money is not fame.
One of my all time favorite humans.
Doug,
the Stan Hope.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Brian Hannigan.
You know we love you.
Thank you.
Fuck with you.
Because you tolerate it.
You gotta fight back.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
You can't keep taking this from us.
It's just not right.
It makes me feel bad.
We'd go after you and we team up on Ya.
I just feel and I'm like,
please fire back.
Ms Dot Hannigan somewhere a storm is
brewing.
Your new nickname is hennessy though
this happened.
It except it didn't get you a sensor
everywhere you go,
the better than Shenanigan or Heineken,
which everyone thinks is hilarious.
Shenanigans.
I liked that even better.
That's like the verbal equivalent of the
Hawaiian shirt and you just gave us two.
We have to choose from Brian Shenanigans
or Brian.
Hi.
He hates worse.
So now we have to choose from like
Tennessee because it makes them
uncomfortable because it's associated
with African Americans.
So I like that better.
That I didn't know that I am phenomena
land.
We don't have.
I didn't know nothing about your coop
Aussie.
A mad dog.
20 slash 20 vision drank is past tense.
What?
This purple drank.
I happened to Lake Mickey's
as you know.
Do you drink orange soda and eat fried
chicken around black people or no?
I beg your pardon?
He doesn't.
He's never around black people.
We cloister him.
Is that a word?
Dogs Calm Talk Mrs.
Rhonda to you via text.
I was going to wear my brown
and I,
I came to my pajamas on.
Sorry.
I came in very comfortable.
I like comfort.
Uh,
this is not fame by Douglas.
Stan.
Hope forward by Drew Pinski,
MD,
Dr.
drew wrote the foreword.
Yeah.
Alright.
A great forward.
Was Dr Phil.
Busy?
No,
Mr Hennessy.
Always good to see you,
my brother very much.
Thank you for being here.
You know we love you,
right?
No.
Okay.
This is a very impressive facility.
Thanks sir.
All right folks.
We'll be back tomorrow with the great
and powerful Chris Stapleton,
one of my favorite musicians tomorrow.
Oh Wow.